Everybody oh, it's so weird being on the left side of the
screen every time I see myself on the left side.
I'm like this is wrong.
This doesn't feel right He's like it was like a little dokey
jump scare like whoa, I'm on the left side.
Oh my god What the fuck is this?
What the fuck is that?
You know like that YouTube video that old YouTube video
where he's like mom?
What the fuck is that kid?
feel about myself right now it's like mom look at that cat
oh my god who the fuck is this the little the little dokey
jump scare because she's on the left side there's a weird
fucking bird ma um anyway hello everybody hello hello today
we're gonna be finishing shadow the colossus i can't believe
i can't believe it after so many five-star reviews she's
gonna close down her massage parlor but why doki i thought
you were having such good business i was having too much of
a good thing you know like the business was going so well
that i can basically retire early i'm retiring like 30 years
early that was just how good the tips were just that good
you know it's like they gave away all their
Like, it was crazy.
Like, they didn't need their life savings anymore.
So, um, no, I didn't run out of clients.
No, no, no, no.
I was just doing such a good job that I'm retiring early,
uh, because, you know, people were just giving me so much
money after I finished my appointments.
It's crazy.
It's like their entire life savings.
It's just deleted so much stress out of them.
Um, I think I've been, like, pretty, uh, you know how I was
like, oh, yeah, I try to finish games in three streams.
I've been, like, I'm, like, so surprised at myself for,
being able to like keep that consistent the consistency of
like finishing a game after like three to four streams and
it's been like super consistent with me so let's hope that i
keep the i keep the pace with competing this game today i'm
gonna i'm gonna not end stream until i kill i mean uh fix
until i fix everybody's problems not kill i don't know where
you heard that Thank you.
Can you give us a summary of the story so far?
Like, last time in Shadow Colossus, thank you, the Super
Chat.
Thank you.
Last time in Shadow Colossus, I cured, I cured a bunch of
Colossi and they were happy.
The end.
Also, I, like, neutered one of them, I think.
I solved the iguana issue.
The invasive species of iguanas.
I solved that, too.
I'm just, I'm just a jack of all trades.
little life update oh my gosh i think like next week uh i
think next week i'm definitely going to uh take a bigger
break next week i'm gonna take like uh double because you
know usually i take sunday off um i think like next week i'm
gonna take sunday and monday off for next week just to like
uh because like one will be because i know it's like rest
day but haven't like rested in any my rest days yeah i mean
so i'm gonna take back to back rest days so one of them will
be the rest day rest day and then the other one will be the
rest work day so i'm gonna do like so next week i'm gonna
take two back to back rest days so like next week's gonna be
like i think like three rest days um and hope that one of
them will actually be resting also thank you for super chat
ninja thank you Thank you.
It's my niece's first birthday.
I thought it would be best to open the credit card in their
name and send you a super chat with that card.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, ninja.
You know what would be even a funnier?
I mean, like, even better idea.
If, like, you just didn't give her that credit card.
You just, you know.
Okay, this is, like, an ethical life hack.
But, like, you know, like, after the kid is born, you know,
open a credit card in their name.
know like you know give them good credit you know they might
have a little bit of debt and then when they hit when they
hit at an age where they have their own money um you can
give them the card and be like don't worry i used it to help
you build up credit now all you have to do is pay off the
debt pay off that all you have to do is pay off the credit
card debt and then you'll have great credit what start them
off young not ruin their credit score it's their fault don't
pay it off like that's credit fraud look i i did say
non-ethical life hack okay i made sure to say it's not that
ethical it's just a little bit not that ethical and like for
legal reasons let me just say this is a joke in case the irs
is watching okay the irs is american what the fuck are you
gonna do to me i'm in canada okay anyway uh might not be
able to visit america anymore after i
But like to all you Americans out there to all you Americans
out there Canadians don't do this because I can be like
child in Canadian court But to all you American to all you
Americans out there The CRA will come for you Anyway Anyway
I saying oh yeah oh my gosh it's been like super duper okay
now fucking Arlo's the main character again ninja thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you this is right only if
you got anyway life updates we have new sub badges to be
fair we've had new sub badges for like a couple of days now
but really haven't had the time to really announce it
because we haven't really had like I was like I think I was
like super tad so I didn't really I forgot to talk about it
but yes Let me see if I can I'll pull it up after the
stream.
I'm not the stream I'll pull it up after we beat the game
like the actual like the the artwork for it But yes, yes,
you some of you guys might have already skipped the tomato
and the egg form So now you're actually dragoons now, but
like we have new sub badges Oh my god, look at all these
dragoons Any fresh tomatoes out there that we can eat
anywhere so speaking of wear tomatoes we have a new doki
bite short um from uh llama and like they really i don't
know if you guys know it but it's actually like a spiritual
continuation of the other short that llama make where like
it was like a magical girl transformation and then the
backwards for like the wear tomato so the wear tomato
transformation i just need you guys to know tone it down a
lot more than what the original was the original was like
the original was was a little bit more graphic just saying I
was like oh yeah no we gotta oh yeah we gotta we gotta
change that up like yo even though this isn't really a
Christian stream like you know this isn't really for kids
But like we don't want to be R-rated, you know, we just want
to be R-rated.
Lord Crow says, thank you for the 10, get the shares, thank
you, thank you.
Also, Trash Boy, welcome back to the tomato farm, welcome,
welcome.
But yes, anyway, so it was originally the quote-unquote
tomato juice was more tomato, tomato, I got flavored, sorry,
was more tomato.
colored i was like oh yeah no let's just dang on rompa this
i was like oh yeah we're gonna have to dang on rompa this a
bit so people you know so youtube won't be like is that
blood because i've got hit by it's very surprising because i
actually didn't get hit by limited for the short because i
said to change it to dang on rompa color for those who don't
know the reference it's like like ketchup you know and then
um um release the llama cut thank you for the super chat
dark blade thank you thank you so i was like yeah let's just
yeah let's make the tomato juices like you know more neon
pink instead of you know tomato ketchup colored because i
don't you know i don't want to fucking i don't want to get
in trouble here and also like the sounds was a lot worse It
was, there was, okay, so there was one where, I don't know,
if you watched the short, there was one where the leaves
were coming out of the head, and then there was the, it was
the sound for that was not great, like, it was very, like,
yeah, and I was like, bro, okay, we're gonna remove the
sound for the head part, because, like, I think, like, you
know, all the others, you know, you can see the stick limbs,
but then on the head, when you hear that sound, it's pretty
bad.
especially when it's at the head so we're gonna i'm gonna
have to ask to remove that because
because i'm worried
so so we had to we had to like tone it down a little bit
because i didn't want to i just want you guys to know the
reason why i asked to tone it down was because like the
experience i've Not on this channel, but there was a short
on another channel that like got hit by limited ads and was
like Was like marked by YouTube because there was like blood
on it and it's they're like no, no, no That's blood So I was
like, so I was like, okay now I know it's funny that the
sound didn't get hit by the limited ads But I think it's cuz
they're like oh, hey look it's not red.
So it's not actually blood.
So you're okay, dokey Yo, like, you're okay, Doki.
I was like, oh my gosh, I was so surprised.
Anyway, artistic integrity is shabbo's plastic.
Thank you, man.
Magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
So I got from that experience, I figured out, like, how to
bypass the, um, how to bypass, like, the censorship on, um,
on YouTube, because apparently at, at companies, like, the
current version.
Also, another funny thing regarding updates.
dates so i was like talking to my youtube guy being like so
why is like some of my vods getting hit by limited recently
because i've never had that experience before and then my
youtube guy was like looking through the vods because like i
have to like i get hit by limited and then after the stream
i get hit by limited and then i have to like appeal it i
have to like actually appeal it and be like why is this hit
by limited like what the fuck's going on and then my youtube
guy looked at it by the way like like the content warning uh
i got hit by limited ads on content warning stream so I got
really confused I was like why the fuck did I get my limited
ads and then I appealed it and then they got like fixed the
date like a couple hours later and then my YouTube guy was
like oh yeah I'm looking through the vibes and I think it's
because of profile
and you're like yeah like you swear a lie I was like, what
the fuck?
I was like, what do you mean?
Profanity.
And he was like, well, you do swear a lot in the beginning
of these videos.
And I think like the auto detection was like, that's a lot
of swearing.
He's like, he's like, I guess it's profanity.
I can't see why else you got hit.
And then, and then I was like, that is bullshit.
Okay, I didn't say that.
I was like, okay, this is why I say it.
I was like, that's so weird because in the past I rarely if
ever got hit by profanity.
So I was like, what do you mean profanity?
I've never changed the way I talk.
I've always had profanity.
Why now?
Why?
I was like, why did I get hit by profanity now of all time?
games so um um so yeah so that's why i've been being hit by
limited but thing is i just have to peel it and then they're
like okay you're good now but it was so weird i was like it
hits me like ever so often like one or two streams like
it'll be like one stream and then the next stream will be
okay or maybe two streams in a row will hit get hit by
limited and the next stream will be okay i just have to peel
it every time i peel it they're like good to go but it's i
was so surprised i like profanity another update another
life update um i've been so fucking busy because like every
day i have like oh my gosh i have like these like business
meetings or like business decisions to make and stuff like
that oh my gosh i don't want to like spoil anything but um
it's been a problem where i have so many it's so difficult i
hate making decisions i hate making choices Especially when
I do want to do everything.
Goodbye, Arlo.
He's going to be the main character again.
Because there's instances where...
So one of these things I can talk about is that, you know,
like, the Doki Bird World Tour.
It's come to a point where we have...
There's, like, so many conventions are asking for me to be a
guest.
That, like, the dates are conflicting with each other.
So I have to pick and choose which convention I want to do.
And I was like, I hate it because I want to do them all!
I wanted to do them all so then I was like oh my gosh like
it's like there's like so many conventions and I was like oh
man I want to do this and I also want to do that and I also
want to do that but I have to pick one because there's only
one dokey bird for those days and I was like no there's so
many so like there's going to be a point where there's going
to be a convention for me like almost every month um we
haven't hit that streak we have obviously like there's no in
April because I got I was a little too late but like we're
gonna have a convention almost like a convention guest
almost every month and it's gonna be like around the world
type deal so it's like oh it won't be like just focusing on
one area just NA or anything just think it's the world tour
for a reason it's the world tour for a reason so just get
ready we're just gonna be a lot of jokey bird so Oh my gosh,
but it makes me so sad because I can only pick like what
like I can only do like what not like Like you know when
there's so many going at the same time like on the same
dates too I think that's the worst part when they're on the
same date and I can only do one and I'm like No, but what if
I want to do them on Is that fair?
But yeah, that's basically what it's been like at the moment
What's going on right now Pasteries?
I know I know But like they're all so fun to do Anyway
Alright, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you
Idea, hire a dokeeper too She can make appearances and
sponsorships for you Easy If only it was that easy.
Anyway, all right, let's actually play.
Let me move myself real fast.
Let's look at a different screen.
All right, time to look at the gaming screen.
All right, that was the life updates.
Now we actually game.
All right, massage parlor is open.
Continue.
The massage parlor is now open.
Alright, where am I?
Hello, that's me.
Don't worry, the specialist is here.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
Time to actually game.
Sorry, it took me 20 minutes to get started, but here we go.
where the fuck where do i go why is my sword not taking me
anywhere oh this way all right arlo arlo let's go arlo arlo
come on come on you had like you had 20 minutes to rest arlo
why are you just walking you had 20 minutes to rest arlo all
right the tangent was necessary to
I can't believe it.
Okay, I can't believe it either.
I can't believe I forgot how to ride a horse.
Alright, let's see.
How do I do this?
Nope, that's duck.
That's my sword.
How do I...
Guys.
Oh, okay.
It's triangle.
I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
Okay, so the next colossal...
My next appointment is like this way.
Here we go.
This is my next appointment.
I have so many projects.
going on behind the scenes but it's actually you're like how
many are you how how much stuff are you doing behind the
scenes i'm like yes every day i wake up to like 20 plus
discord messages i was like i wake up i was like oh dear are
the messages well time to answer some discord messages That
was actually crazy.
We have so many.
Like, I know, like, the last couple of weeks there hasn't
been anything, like, really...
I don't know.
We haven't really have anything, like, major, big on the
channel yet.
But, like, it's because, like, there's so many things going
on.
And behind the scenes, that's going to build up soon.
So we can actually have something fun on the channel.
How do I...
Is it, like, this way?
I guess it's on the...
It has to be on the other side.
We're still cooking.
We're cooking so many things right now.
Back to back.
Cease.
You're gonna burn out.
Guys, the thing is, I'm like a huge workaholic.
But like, also like, I still, I do need, like, rest days,
though.
The reason why I have rest days is because I do want to rest
at some points.
But, like, I mean, like, I can, like, work as well on the
rest day.
But, like, I just want to, like, not talk.
Like, you know, be like, be like a...
mute for a day and i think like that's what's like like
tilting for me when i have to like do like actually use my
mouth when i have to actually like talk and like do like
business meetings and make like business decisions on my
rest day like but i can't like do it via text i'm fine if
like it's via text or something like oh make this decision
and then like have i been here before Have I killed the
salamander here before?
Time to pray.
But, like, if it's like...
I don't know.
Actually, can't tell.
I can't tell.
All these shrines are blurring together.
Oh, no, I haven't!
Look, there's a salamander right here!
But, like, um, if I have to, like, use my mouth during my
resting, that's when I get tilted.
That's when I'm like, please, please, I just want to be a
mute for a day and not talk.
and make sure my throat will be okay.
Where the fuck is that bitch?
I thought we solved the invasive species issue.
Where is it?
Where is he?
Hello?
Where the fuck is he?
Where did he go?
Hello?
Little iguana, boy?
Where the fuck is he?
Where did he go?
Alright, we're gonna have to climb.
Guys, give me a second.
You remember how to climb?
Guys, the most important mechanic.
Give me a second.
Okay, alright.
It's RT.
I'm gonna fucking grab some HP.
Oh my gosh, no.
Where did he go?
I don't see him anymore.
He vanished.
Alright.
Give me this way.
Okay.
And then...
This way That's to show up somewhere.
Oh, I climbed this Oh, I climbed this Oh my god, excuse me
There's nothing I can grab oh there it is all right there
you go and got it Thanks Arlo for just watching me and not
helping at all All right, he has to be here.
Oh there he is.
That's what can rise to you.
Oh, you bitch You fucker, okay?
Okay, he dropped down?
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
Oh, you little fuck.
Okay, I see you.
I see you.
Can't hide from me forever.
I'm gonna fucking eat you.
No!
Okay.
I'm gonna eat you soon.
It might not be now.
But I swear to God, I'm gonna eat you.
Okay, let's... I can figure out how to climb up again.
Ugh.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck do I climb?
Okay, here you go.
Okay, this one has to be the hardest one.
The other one, the others just like walked into my mouth.
I don't know why.
Why don't you want to be consumed?
Like, why not?
It'll be like a fun journey to my stomach.
Alright, here we go.
Up, up.
Yay!
Oh, up.
There we go.
Where the fuck is Salamander again?
Where did he go?
Where is he?
Oh, I hear him.
No!
Stop!
I hear his feet.
They're like Bomberman feet.
Okay.
Where is he?
Okay, if I do it like this, will he, like, if I stealth,
maybe if I stealth like this, he'll show up.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, climb back up.
Please, I need that stamina.
Where did he go?
How did you see me?
Oh, oh, he didn't see me.
He didn't see me.
He's just casually back there.
This is so fucked up.
How the fuck do I get to here?
Okay, what if I, like...
Oh, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
I'm just gonna slowly walk to the other side.
I'm gonna slowly walk to the other side and then like I'll
have the perfect angle on him right here come on you gotta
get up you gotta climb up you can't hang in there forever oh
there you go the perfect angle nice okay there you go that's
gonna hit the side watch this okay now watch this There he
got told you!
Where did he go?
Oh my god, he has to be dead.
There's no way he's alive.
Oh yeah, he fucking disappeared.
Thank god.
That has to be the hardest one so far.
I knew it.
Alright, time to kill... Now time to kill the colossi.
Alright, where is it?
Nope, that's not the sword.
When will I get a magic bow?
I feel like I deserve it.
This way, okay.
All right.
Thank you to that backseater that told me that I don't have
to actually navigate my horse.
I don't have to actually move my horse.
He does the auto-travel for me.
Okay, where is that?
Where the fuck is that?
Is this?
There's no aces here.
God, I wish the maps actually work.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Have I consumed these fruits before?
No, I haven't.
All right, it's fruit time.
It's time to eat the fruit.
All right, let's see.
Fruit time.
Snack break.
All right.
Poop.
Can horses just eat grass and survive?
Or do they actually need real food?
Is it possible if you just like...
Oh, hey.
Did they just eat grass?
Can they survive?
Wait, that's really?
They don't need actual hay?
So, like, I can just leave a horse in somebody's backyard
and they'll be okay.
Can we live off grass?
So, like, does that mean, like, humans can live off grass,
too?
Are we just, like, fucked?
Because, like, grass is vegetables.
You think about it?
No?
Why not?
Why can animals live off grass if we can't?
they still need water there's water on grass like grass need
water to live and then like if grass need water to live it's
like cactus when you eat a cactus there's water inside we
can't digest grass you need more stomachs to digest grass
god we're so fucking weak why can't we genetically modify
ourselves dude that this is why we need survival the fittest
we should so you know how like for insects you know how like
we selected bred them and wait that's eugenics wait that's
bad disregard everything
guys that was a joke guys that was a joke Guys, that was a
joke.
That was a joke.
That was a fucking joke, guys.
Pull back.
We don't need six stomachs, guys.
No, we don't need six stomachs.
We're fine.
We don't need six stomachs, guys.
One is good enough.
Why would we need to eat grass?
Don't be fucking stupid, chat.
Don't be fucking...
Don't be stupid.
What is enough?
Why would we need all these?
Where the fuck is my son GPS?
Where is my son GPS?
Oh my god!
We're in a desert and I don't have a GPS.
How do I live?
Oh, it's right here.
It's right here.
Don't deny me my third stomach like this.
all I'm saying is that okay you know how like how stick
insects are born like how we've like how stick insects like
evolved basically like it's not that they know what sticks
look like is that eventually the insect like you know the
insects that don't look like a stick got eaten up too many
times by the birds and then like at one point that the
insects that looked like sticks were able to live on and
like breed like crazy and then become the sick insects that
it's become so like we should ethically speaking it's so
fucked up but like don't double down what if like okay what
if okay what if like all right there's gonna be a little bit
of like uh like like philosophy of thing Like, it's gonna be
based off that movie with, like, Andrew Garfield, where,
like, the clone, we clone, we start cloning.
Like, at one point, we're gonna be able to start cloning.
And then we clone, like, these people.
We start cloning ourselves, but they have, like, no...
Because they're clones.
You know, they have, you know, they're not real...
They're not real people, if you think about them.
Okay.
So, like, so, like, we put these clones.
We put these clones in a room, and it's just grass.
And the room will just be grass.
You know?
And then, and then, so, like, the thing is, um, the thing
is, eventually the clone with the three, eventually the
clones will evolve until, until...
I'm not ignoring him.
Try to figure out the GPS right now.
the clones will evolve in a way where they eventually have
more than one stomach because we just put them in a room
filled with grass and then at one point at one point the
clones will be able to have all they'll be able to evolve
into like people with like more than one stomach and then we
take those clones and then they are now they and then like
you know we we put them with the real humans And then
they'll make peepa babies from the clone DNA with like more
than one stomach.
There you go.
Where the fuck is the entrance?
Is it here?
Have I been like dodging this hole this entire?
No, that's not a...
That does not look like a safe hole.
That is...
Unless...
It has to be here.
where else would it be i've been like fucking walking around
to the same hole multiple times it has to be this hole where
else could it be okay this seems safe right it is a safe
what if i'm just trying to make the optimal human where we
can survive off grass alone food shortages we can literally
just go outside and eat the grass if we have more than one
stomach like think about it guys if we have more than one
stomach then we can just eat grass and then it'll be like
optimal survival the optimal human because like at that
point we'll have like enough we'll we'll be able to like
consume oh my god it's all the way over there okay but what
if i just It can't be that bad.
I mean, I already prayed.
Okay, guys.
Alright.
Guys, I'm stuck.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
No!
Guys.
Woo!
I'll live.
I lived!
I fucking knew it!
I knew it would work.
I knew it would work, guys.
I'm a fucking genius.
Arlo, get down from here.
I lived I lived Guys this is it guys I am the ultimate human
being If we like If we clone me And
Guys Guys We can have like Doki clones that can survive
bigger falls Guys Think about it I can't see this What the
fuck is Where am I going Oh, is it here?
This has to be it.
Total dokification.
Guys, just think about how many, like, conventions I can go
to.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck do I do here?
Whoa!
Ow!
Okay.
Where am I?
Where?
Where did he fucking knock me?
Alright, guys.
We got the...
Where am I?
Oh, it's this way.
How the fuck did he knock me off?
What the fuck?
Okay, here we go.
Here we go again.
Alright.
I can barely see the stage.
What the fuck do I do?
Arrow?
Okay, arrow.
you don't you like that you can't get me because you can't
walk up ramps he he where the do i go what a loser yeah you
wish you can get me right now i bet you yeah that's right
that's right i'm here for the session guys acupuncture if i
can't even see where the acupuncture all right where is his
fucking heart oh yeah there's no sun um all right we haven't
wait where am i i jumped down again sorry guys i i jumped
down
Okay, this time This time it's so hard to see bro turn off
your fucking brightness How how I don't know?
Turn up your fucking brightness?
I can barely see where it starts Okay, I'm here.
I'm here now.
Oh my god.
I need to climb up Can I climb up this We're like go near
the fire.
All right.
I'm near the fire.
Here I am.
I have the light now I have the high ground.
What are you gonna do about it?
Oh That's right nothing Can't do anything about it I live
here now Wait what's this?
Oh shit Guys I was just joking sir Sir sir sir I was just
joking Please let me get up sir Sir please Sir please do Sir
please do not sunlock me sir This is not a fighting game Sir
please Where am I We're even in my oh there it is.
I see it.
I see it
Please sir, let me grab the torch.
No I can barely see the fucking screen All right, let's here
we go again guys guys I swear to guy This is like the most
different.
It's so dark.
Oh My god, I can fit.
Okay, here you go I'm gonna fall.
I feel like I'm gonna fall again, bro.
Why are you edgeguarding?
Are you fucking playing smash bros or some shit?
Oh god.
Be gone.
Ow
Don't think he likes it Is this even on fire?
No, it's not.
No.
Let me climb!
Please.
At least let me get up, please.
Oh, God.
This is so fucked up, man.
This is actually so fucked up.
I can...
Oh, God.
I'm okay.
Guys, it's okay.
guys it's okay i'm okay guys don't worry oh thank god oh
thank god he stopped oh thank god he stopped all right here
you go yeah and god said let there be light ow okay all
right begun begun
Go to the lights!
I need light to work!
Sir!
There you go.
We're fine.
Oh, thank God.
Alright.
That's all we have to do.
We took off his clothes.
It'll be fine.
Where is he?
Where the fuck did he land?
Where did his body go?
What the fuck?
he's gone where is his body is he lying all the way here oh
he did what the fuck why is he here okay knife time stabby
stab wee all right there we go there we go oh my god thank
fucking god bro okay look at all the stress juice in your
back sir those not healthy men keeping all that inside you
oh god oh oh sir we got a cracker i'm a chiropractor too now
as well i just got my chiropractor license guys i'm a
licensed chiropractor oh my god did you guys ever see the
youtube video of chiropractors for dogs and i'm just like
how that's like the scariest shit ever doing power fucking
fucking doing that to dogs please guys i'm like that i'm
like that guy in gumbo where he has when he's like
everywhere because he has so many jobs and license that's me
that's me i gotta make money somehow okay please please just
let me poke you in the back oh god oh my god i don't know
why he doesn't like it like a little scratch okay all right
one two more stabs maybe please please no no no no no no no
no okay what if i just stand here like this okay sorry i
recharged a little whoa it's okay i'll just stand here like
this what no no no i had to do it again oh god oh please get
up why is your the choices of youtube thank you for the
super chat task thank you thank you how is your recovery
rate this bad all right can you jump here i'm gonna do it
again where did i leave my fucking stick though like oh no i
don't know where i left my stick all right can i can you
jump over here here can he get here where is he where did he
go sir where did he go did I fall down again I fucking I got
where did he go oh he's behind me isn't he oh shit okay guys
he was behind me how do I get up
He got bored.
But how do I, oh God, please don't slap me.
Please don't slap me.
Oh, oh, that's okay.
That's okay.
We're gonna figure this out.
Get up.
Oh, that's okay.
He can't kill me.
What doesn't kill me?
Miss me stronger.
Oh, no, no, no, it's okay.
I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay.
up Jesus Christ how do I get back up do you know where the
exit is sir
can you get downstairs oh god there must be a way there must
be a way oh fuck okay I did not mean to I don't know guys I
don't know how to get back up I don't know how to get back
onto his back, guys.
Mippy Hill.
Oh, I have an idea.
Watch this.
He's going to be so confused.
There's no way.
He's going to go right here, and then I can be like, Oh,
wait, that works!
Oh!
Of course it works.
I've planned it all along.
Guys, of course that works.
I always knew it was going to work.
I'm a licensed professional.
Oh, my, please.
Why is this so...
Why is he so difficult?
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Okay, we're almost there.
We just need two more pokes.
Sir, calm down.
Calm down.
It doesn't hurt too bad.
That's not playing.
You just have so much stress on your back.
Please.
We just need to hear a good crack.
There we go.
He don't want to die.
He's not gonna die.
I'm a licensed professional
Die guys
Another client satisfied Yeah, you guys see the chiropractor
for dogs is actually crazy You can like cure to crack while
he tries the fucking break of dogs while he was out breaking
the dogs back but like it's so disturbing because it's like
how do you know if they like it like how do you know they
actually like that they can't verbally tell you be like that
that that is not helping
that's the neat part they don't just ask the dog hey little
doggy was Is that a happy yelp or a not happy yelp?
You guys never seen it?
Okay, wait, I'm gonna find that YouTube video.
Paradise floats upon the lake aside.
No, it's gonna be water again.
no not the water colossas i think that's the worst ones the
water ones are the worst the water ones and the ones that
had to do with the horse uh because i'm not very good at
driving horses gary thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you man doki got beat up for real for real and i know
i was just trying to help i can't believe it they don't
trust professionals okay tyro factor for animal for dogs I
saw it on Twitter and I was like
Oh my god bro Some of them Like he does it to like tiny dogs
too And I'm like What the And you can see like the dogs
They're like what the fuck
Oh my god The one with the corky Like I'm the cork is like
Jesus Christ I'm trying to find the one with like um the one
where he was like hold like he like hugged the dog and he's
like po like i'm like i think it was this one yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was this one but check this
video out the corgi was like no
oh my god the one where he like fucking it's like a
wrestling move where he like picks up the I'm like what the
fuck I don't know They're like it improves the standard of
living I'm like but you don't even know what If they're They
can't talk I'm just like How do you know Snap crackle and
pop If I write chat plastic Thank you for the magenta soup
Thank you thank you Alright let me Let me, uh, pray real
fast.
They looked relaxed.
I just wondered, like, how do you trial and error it
correctly to become a professional, too?
Because it's like, dog skeletons are not the same as human
skeletons.
So, I'm just like, how- Y'all just all look very- Yeah,
because they're like, what the fuck?
a dog because like they're like what the fuck is this person
doing and like suddenly their bones feel different like oh
my god that's not like that's so freaking freaky
it's like oh my god like how we invent stuff you don't think
like how long it took for us to in bed.
Okay, this is fucked up for me to say, but it's like, when
did we figure out how to neutering?
It's like, it's similar.
It's similar.
The trial and error.
When did we figure out how how neutering works?
It's, all of them stop smiling after.
How long did it take?
The same with poison.
The fact that we know what's poisonous and what's not.
Like, you have to remember how many times it takes us to,
like, figure out which mushrooms we can eat and which we
can't.
It's like, there's, like, mushrooms that look the same to
each other.
And then...
And then we have to, like, figure out what mushroom was,
like, poisonous and which one wasn't.
There's some of the...
Yeah, they're like, what the fuck?
They're like, the fuck?
All right, we go...
Is this the water?
Is the water there?
Wait, is it underneath here?
It's like how, like, back in the medieval times, there would
be poison testers.
We know, yeah, exactly.
Experience.
Not our experience.
Oh, no.
Not the wand.
We gotta find...
How many links are here?
all right we gotta find another lake we gotta find another
lake chat it's a never-ending cycle of lakes we're no oh my
god please arlo please arlo please find me a lake all right
here all right here
Salute to all those dogs we've tested to the perfect
Salute to the falls Hey, there you go This way, this has to
be where the lake is
Is this a lake?
This has to be, there's water here Okay, how do I get down
here?
Can I die from this lake?
There's no way.
There's no way I'll die from this lake, right?
No, that seems like a pretty deep lake.
Never mind.
I mean, that's...
Okay.
Is it this lake?
Is it this one?
Is this the lake?
Not this one?
God.
God, there's way too many lakes.
Oh, is it this one?
It has to be this lake.
Do I get down?
though is this lake it's pointing there how many other lakes
are there this has to be the only lake the bridge oh okay
wait you're right there is a bridge there jump do it dokey
it'll be so funny all right we're gonna go to that bridge it
has to be the bridge over there i'm never like i don't know
has anyone ever went to chiropractor before it's always so
scary whenever I see videos of people doing chiropractor
like what is it called chiropract what is the verb whenever
someone went to get chiropracted like what's the word for it
chiropractor chiropractic like like it's always so scary
because um because it's like they pull like there's ones
where uh they pull a they pull your neck up and stuff and
then you hear a fucking crack and like jesus christ like it
just looks painful in a way to not like excuse the shitter
of me they just call it chiropractice i don't know like the
fact that your entire body is like you know what if they
bent the rod sorry I might be giving people internal fears
right now and like never go to kyle practice or anything
because of what I'm saying but like but what if like it's
just weird because they're like putting their entire body
and just hear like crack sound and shit like that that's so
fucking scary to me you are just like me in planes
please why don't you are those Why aren't you going?
Oh my god, I'm just gonna walk over.
God damn it, Arlo.
He doesn't like the fucking water stream.
And I don't know why.
Where's this?
Here?
Can I jump down?
Guys, we cannot jump down.
Do not.
Do not jump down.
But where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
Where the fuck is that bridge?
It's not here.
Maybe the other side?
Do a flip.
Guys, I'm not going to try, guys.
I don't want to walk back down.
Doki, don't worry.
You can make that jump.
You totally can't.
Guys, I don't know.
Whenever you guys say do it, for some reason, I feel like I
can't.
Trial and error, Doki.
Remember what you said.
This is not the same thing, and you know it.
the same.
It has to be here.
You can.
Not with that attitude.
Don't do it.
Guys, I'm getting like different.
I'm getting like conflicting answers here.
Is it not here?
Where does my light tell me to go?
There's literally a sun.
What is my... It's like here.
it's in there how the fuck do i get in there there's no way
i cannot even see the end the waterfall just stops watering
like it doesn't even head downstairs it just stops
like what why did it stop there has to be like a cave right
where the lake came from right it has to be well nope that's
where the lake is oh my god i'm so lost arlo i'm so it
doesn't even head downstairs okay how much money would you
guys bet on it if you bet money on it are you right wait
wait there's a hole here There's a hole here.
Guys.
Guys, there's an extra hole.
Wait, maybe it's here.
There's an extra hole here that I didn't go through.
Look how Arlo's just trailing behind me.
Wait, have I been here?
That's a shrine, right?
I think I've been here before.
There's a shrine right here.
Have I been here before?
This has to be it, right?
Oh no, this is where I came from.
Guys, sorry.
This is...
sorry my gps malfunction there this is exactly where i've
been deja vu guys deja vu oh my god where the fuck do i go
like it's just empty it's just nowhere is there a bridge
there there has to be like a bridge somewhere it can't just
be like nothing why would there be a cliff here why the fuck
okay I'm gonna do it I don't know for some reason the main
character is so scared and I don't know why guys why does he
seem so scared about jumping down guys why does unless it's
not the right way Better.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Red, quit horsing around.
Don't you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I did.
I followed the water.
There was, like, multiple waters.
Followed.
I did!
This is it.
They won't let me go forward.
Okay.
I'll find.
I'll follow this trail.
of water where does this trail of water lead to oh nowhere
oh nothing look at that nothing it just leads me to this
which is nothing check the map i am checking the map what am
i looking at what
try the underwater there was nothing here it's nothing okay
climb it climb what climb what the fucking air guys wait
what the fuck is this oh okay I got like a token guys I got
an Easter Rick, was that it?
That opening over there.
It's right there, Jokey.
God, open your eyes.
Alright, we're gonna go check the other fucking opening
then.
Guys, the next opening is the fucking waterfall!
That's another waterfall!
What do you mean there?
It's literally water!
Water!
It's right there, Doki.
It's right there.
Oh my god, circle emoji.
Right there.
You just ran past it again, Doki.
Oh my god.
Stop running past it.
Follow the water, not on the water.
Oh my god.
How many waters do I i follow all right fine i'm gonna
follow the water again i'm following the water i'm following
it whoa where is this water gonna take me whoa oh my god
water right here whoa it's like no holes here at it am i
even in the right hole like am i supposed to be here like
this is insane guys i swear to fucking god am i actually not
missing it am i am i like actually like too blind to see the
fucking hole like there's no way there's actually a hole
here that i'm missing i refuse to believe i'm actually
missing something it's hard to find the hole there's a road
that follows is this not the road
is this there's other holes where do the where are the other
holes oh my god go back this is what we called the river all
right all right let's see chat gps let's go it's like chat
gpt but like more confusing apparently all right here we go
is that hole right here no that's just the water that's not
the hole all right we're following the river we're following
the river see the open that way there's an opening i think
yeah we hundred percent need yellow paint What opening?
Leave the woods where you came in and followed the...
There's more to the canyon?
Was I not even supposed to be in the fucking forest?
Oh my fucking god, I'm leaving.
Apparently I'm not even supposed to be in this forest, guys.
I can't...
Guys, that's all you have to say.
Leave the forest.
Guys, you could have said leave.
the fucking forest chat that's all you had to say i would
have left the forest there you go there's the hole i found
the hole guys guys i figured it out i left the goddamn
fucking forest and then there's another area
guys who would have thought there was more to life than the
forest there it is all right we did it we figured it out
guys guys i don't know why none of you guys said leave the
forest why did all of you make me go with why did all you
fucking said follow the river a whole new hole we had a good
time at the forest we could have left the forest guys we
didn't have to be in the forest all right here we go can't
believe some of you guys were like just jump I'm not gonna
guys I would jump only if the safe spot wait he has a white
tail oh it's because this is a shrine I was like wait
where's the shrine for this all right I'm gonna burn that
forest down unless forest there are unless I'll get lost
guys for legal reasons that is a joke i used to be president
of the environmental club i would never willingly burn the
forest down whoop there you go where is he is he's still
alive oh he is not anymore wait what oh yeah he's dead not
anymore god good more stamina all right here oh there you go
I got down.
Sorry.
There we go.
Now!
This has to be the lake.
Oh my god, there's the lake.
How the fuck do I get into the lake?
Oh, I have to climb.
Okay.
Alright.
Don't worry, Arlo.
You can swim too, Arlo, right?
Arlo, just do the jump.
It'll be so funny.
Arlo!
It'll be so funny if you make that jump.
You have more momentum!
We actually made it to the lake.
Oh, thank fucking god.
we made it holy shit there's way too many lakes in this area
there's way too many fucking lakes guys all right that'll
not go yay he has to be here right all right is it faster if
I swim underwater it is right sorry I can hold my breath for
a long time i ate in the the more salamander tails you eat
the longer you can hold your breath real i learned this in
the video game guys every time because we all know video
games are so real where is he where is this monster oh why
is there like three podiums there yeah of course i eat those
salamander tails me guys i'm thinking like can salamander
tails be food because like it's like an infinite food glitch
you know you get a bunch of salamanders and like you know
they can regrow their tails right so like all you i feel
like if i had this conversation i feel like i've had this
conversation before but but like think about it like um
because like the tails are still meat you know just you just
you just like farm a bunch of salamanders and then and then
all you do is just you know every time you're hungry you eat
the salamander tail and then wait for it to regrow and then
and then but then you have like a farm of them and they just
they don't always grow back then you just kill it it's we're
back to selective breeding like we evolved oh shit that
guy's cool We involve the ones that, like, that grow their
tails faster.
Okay, we keep them on a farm.
It's like the whole grass thing again.
And then...
Oh, shit.
Ow, that hurt.
But he has electricity and water?
Oh, my God.
That's fucked up.
Why do you have electricity power?
It's fucking water.
You're just gonna, like, electrocute yourself.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Okay, he doesn't see me.
You can't.
This is not realistic.
I should have been electrified as well as all the fish
around me.
No, all I'm saying is infinite food glitch.
Just think about it.
It's literally an infinite food glitch because they can grow
back their tails.
So, like, if you're hungry, you just eat the tails and
they're still alive.
They're still alive, right?
So, oh my God, please for the love of God, where can I climb
you?
you stop following me okay oh this is not fair because he
turns faster than me swimming like how the fuck am I
supposed to figure this out yeah we feed the bugs bugs
reproduce so fast salamanders eat bugs right so like oh god
okay so like all we do is we oh wait I see it I see it it's
a tail it's a tail my tail theory it's the tail theory guys
all over again okay It's the tail theory.
We climb the tail.
Oh my god, please for the love of God.
Maybe I'll swim faster than the weight.
Maybe if I swim faster, it'll work.
Oh my god, I fucking knew it's the tail.
Alright, here you go.
Here you go.
I knew it.
I knew it was gonna be the tail.
It's always the tail.
That's just the theory.
Tail theory.
Oh, I'm seeing.
Like, salamanders, they just need...
bugs, right?
And bugs reproduce crazy fucking fast.
So like, if you're hungry, we give the salamander bugs and
then... What?
Where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
Why does he have like teeth on his head?
Where do I take him?
Why is he at like... What?
Why is there teeth on his head?
That's not where you... Why do you have teeth on your head?
Oh god, oh god.
There's no shit.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Oh, that's got to hurt if you hit the tooth straight on.
Oh, I can steer it.
Like a steering wheel.
It's like my very own car.
Bro, this is better than a horse.
Although, I don't mean it.
You know that because I still need you.
You know I don't mean it.
You know, it's like a xylophone teeth.
Can I, like, take him to, like, the other claw?
I assume I have to go here, right?
Like, where else would I fucking go?
Now I'm a dentist.
Guys, now I'm a licensed dentist now.
Guys, I'm here to...
Look at all these cavities!
Bro, you need a dentures or braces.
Honestly, you definitely need braces.
This tooth is, like, so fucking overgrown.
Like, holy shit.
You 100%.
You need a fucking dentist.
What do I do?
I'm up here now.
Hello.
Oh!
Hello?
What do I do?
I'm here.
What are you doing?
Oh, what are you doing?
Oh, my God.
You're giving me your belly?
What do I do here?
Oh!
Oh, my God!
Okay, guys.
He needs a belly rub.
Isn't that cute?
Guys, he needs a little belly rub here.
Don't worry.
Those juices.
It's just all the oil from excitement.
Oh shit!
Fuck, okay.
Alright, don't worry, I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay.
I just gave him a little belly rub and he got a little too
excited.
Guys, come on, let me through.
Let me through.
It's like a dentist, like, okay, if a dentist gives you
belly rub, that is not a licensed dentist.
Just silly.
But I'm different.
I'm different.
I'm a specialist.
If a dentist after your procedure tries to give you belly
rubs, I don't think that's a real dentist, guys.
I think you might.
I think you might got scammed.
Unless it's jokey.
I'm a specialist.
It's like my thing.
I was like, you know, children dentists where like there's
dentists that are just primarily for kids and they have
these like weird ass offices like kid themed dentist
offices.
I was watching a video where there was a dentist there was a
dentist that specializes on just children and then the thing
is like their entire office was like they have an elevator
in their office like in the procedure room to entertain kids
and I'm like Jesus fucking like they have an actual like
mini elevator where where they do like some willy walk a
shit some willy walk a shit to like make the kids feel
comfortable but it's still like fucking crazy oh god oh sir
i know you gotta stop eating candy look at your overgrown
teeth it's like the bread oh okay i'm okay um i didn't i
didn't uh I didn't ply anything.
Alright, here we go.
We can climb.
That was close.
I'm holding off for dear life right now.
I don't know what you're talking about, guys.
I don't know what you're talking about.
This is how dentist works.
You guys might not know because you don't see your own
mouth.
This is what the dentist looks like when you're fixing...
When they're fixing your teeth.
You just smack it until something happens.
Turn around.
Keep turning.
Who keeps hitting my cavities?
This is why they put, like, those, um...
Those, like, anesthesia?
No, not anesthesia.
What are those things that make your fucking mouth numb?
This is what they do.
You just whack it.
I love my Eldritch Horror Dentist, Ariel.
That should be it, right?
Woo!
whoa whoa whoa whoa that's fine we're fine all right you
want a little belly rub after getting rid of that cavity you
need that little belly rub don't worry don't worry i'm a
specialist i'm a specialist every time i i fix a teeth i
give a belly rub to make you feel better i wonder if dog
dances i wonder like if you get paid more to be a dog
dentist than a regular dentist because like I feel like vets
can make so much more money than like like any oh no my
platform how would I give you the belly rub oh tummy hurt
how would I give you the belly rub sir guys it's because I
did too much of a good job it's not belly robes were fucking
shit there's another platform oh my god I need to swim again
swim swim swim no more belly sir I can't keep give I can't
give you belly robes that you destroyed my platform all I'm
saying is that I feel like your profession is like animal
related you get paid so much more only because I feel like
he has like we love our pets so fucking much that we will
like oh my god is back too we love our pets so much more
that we will spend a lot of money especially for like dog
dentistry there you go sir you haven't fixed your teeth yet
we gotta give you braces on the head sir how the fuck did
you like got get cavities on your head what are you feeding
oh my god please where's the other platform i don't even
know where the other oh it's over there it's on the right
side all right here we go we may give you adult braces don't
worry some people are into that oh sorry for laughing oh
down you go
sorry i went the wrong way my gps isn't working all right
here you go oh fuck okay sorry i said sorry i'm sorry for
hitting the fucking gums i said sorry look you wanted the
cheap dentist okay look you could have got a real dentist
that only specializes on teeth but you've got the
chiropractor dentist acupuncturist massage parlor neuter is
that's not my Fuck.
You could have went for the real deal.
I am real.
But he could have went for the actual specialist dentist
that only works on teeth.
I'm the one with being good at a lot.
Like, being decent at a lot of things means that you're not
good at one thing.
So all I'm saying is that I might not have as much time
doing it.
head teeth versus like massage massages
Jack of all's yeah exactly Jack of all trades master no
exactly Look it doesn't I might be able to have a license on
all of them, but it doesn't mean I am the best at all
Guys I just have a certificate I like pass It doesn't mean I
got a good grade.
It just means I passed.
It just means like that.
Another happy client.
Speaking of chief specialists, did you see Conan and Brian's
hot ones episode where he brought that totally legit doctor
with him?
Long time.
Thank you.
Super chat.
I want to watch his stuff.
He's like, uh, He's really I think like any comedian because
like I feel like in order to like master comedy You have to
be like really smart.
I feel like like a lot of like really good like it's so come
like Universal comedy like things that make people who are
the fuck are these people are they trying to encroach in my
territory Guys, I claim this territory.
This is my neuter massage acupuncturist dentist area.
I claim that it's like it's like gangs like this is my turf.
What are you fuck are you doing?
get out of my turf
but I feel like like because you have to be smart to be able
to write humor that's like funny that's universally funny um
and like especially humor that sort of transcends like uh
transcends like uh language barriers and like a lot of my
favorite comedians yeah to write good humor a lot of my
favorite comedians I went to like are like ivy league
graduates too and i feel like a good comedian actor can make
can like uh can be an amazing are like i mean can be like
what is this the vast desert oh no not the desert not the
fucking dry lakes
i feel like a lot of comedians are really good actors in
general because like you have to be a really good actor to
make comedy movies work to make a comedy movie seem natural
i feel like especially improv too to be you have to be like
really smart to be able to do improv correctly because like
there can be like super cringe improv like i feel like a lot
of like super good actors like super good comedian actors
they're actually like really good actors in general adam
sandler my favorite actor okay when adam sandler actually
does drama he's a really good actor but he just gets paid
more being a comedian because he just like he doesn't he
doesn't do indie movie films a lot or drama because indie
films and movie films don't pay as much and because of that
um because of that he just does uh he just does like
comedies because he gets a bigger deal Like it gets a bigger
like move gets a bigger pay cut Because if you think like if
you think like like the Netflix deal he had that paid so
much money And then you're like okay like that movie he did
a pixel You know the worst fucking Adam one of the worst
fucking Adam Sandler movie of all time He basically hired
all his friends so like that they get free paid vacation
He literally did he did that movie so he could get like a
free paid vacation um because he doesn't care he just wants
to have like he just hear the fucking make money to support
his family and his friends yeah all he does is just hire his
friends so his friends can get paid and also and also like
um he can get paid as well i can't forgive him for pics but
then when he does like drama movies he's actually really
like i i like watched uncut gems But I could only watch up
to like a certain point because it was just So good and like
it is like you know what a movie is like for me when a movie
is too good And depressing I just stopped watching because I
got too fucking depressed watching it I was just like oh my
god this feels too real and then I stopped watching it
because it was way Too real and I was like bro I'm getting
really sad and then I stopped but it was good it was a good
movie but like i was just super anxious watching it because
it was so fucking high tension and then uh it was like super
high tension and then like super depressing and i had to
stop watching it because it was actually too good
but yeah that's why i that's honestly what i believe i feel
like comedians are like a lot of comedians or the comedy
actors and actresses are like really good at acting in
general because it takes a lot of skill to make comedy
movies work in general because like you gotta it has you
have to try to make it not cringe like what's your name uh i
say kate mckinnon uh oh my gosh where the Fuck the alcohol.
Who is that desert?
Is it Kate McKinnon that...
I'm trying to remember.
No, not Kate McKinnon.
There's the other one.
The other one...
Before Kate McKinnon, there's the other one.
Try to remember.
There was this female actress that's, like, been in a lot of
comedy films.
The wife of Despicable...
The wife of the guy who's in Despicable...
Okay.
I'm trying to remember what...
other role she did, but all I can remember is the wife of...
Oh, Kristen Whig!
Yes!
Kristen Whig!
Okay, you know Kristen Whig in a lot of, like, um, in a lot
of, like, comedy films, but she has done, like, some drama
stuff.
Like, they're, like, sort of Indies, though.
They're, like, indie films, but she's such a good actress.
I watched, like, I'm trying...
There was, like, one she did where she was, like,
apparently, like, pretending to...
Like, not pretending.
She was, like, a twin sister of Bill Hader or something.
Like, that was the plot.
And like, also Bill Hader too.
Bill Hader in that movie where he's the assassin, that one
was really good as well.
That movie, that TV series, where he was, like, he plays an
assassin.
He's such a good actor.
Barry, yes!
Barry!
I love that show.
That show was really good.
Look, I just really love comedians because I think comedians
are, like, are like super talented in general um a lot of
them are actually like crazy smart
bill bill bill i think i did i not fucking ate the
salamander in this one already i feel like i did because
like i don't see the salamander
where the is the no i must have eaten the salamander
What?
Did I eat this guy already?
I feel like I have.
I don't see him.
I don't hear the flip-flop of his feet.
I've been here?
Yeah, I have.
I've been here already.
Yeah.
Like, this place has been discovered already.
I don't hear the flip-flop of the feet, too, so I think I
ate him.
I ate his family already.
Oh, no.
I've lost now.
There's no GPS.
Sun GPS.
Where are you when I needed you the most?
Where are you?
Where am I?
Sun GPS?
Okay, this way.
Okay, there's a little sun GPS right there.
I think it's this way.
Right?
Where else can it be?
Okay, the little hole.
There, it's this way.
I found the little hole for my sword GPS.
It has to be this way.
Where else could it be?
Yeah, it's this way.
to go i've been here before no this way okay arlo i figured
it out arlo come over here i found the exit arlo i did it
guys i think oh wait no i can climb up right wait a minute
wait a minute why is there no up Wait a minute Wait a minute
Why is this just tree here?
Well at least I can eat that fruit Maybe I'll just eat the
fruit then Okay fine right Food time
Wait wouldn't that like drop to the water Oh Oh,
yeah, it did.
Wait, how the...
Oh, wait, it did.
Okay, that was useless.
That's...
That was fucking useless.
What the fuck?
Why do I get up?
Why does this leave me to nowhere?
Oh, wait.
Can I go up from here?
Why does this let me...
Wait, what?
Where do I go?
Do I go down?
Is that it?
Maybe.
There's no way it's not down, right?
Down is up.
We've learned that.
Yeah, see, I'm okay.
Down is up.
But where do I go?
Where did that poop go?
Guys, I don't know if I should have went down.
guys i don't know where am i where the fuck am i up is up
guys i don't know if down is up anymore guys we're not
supposed to be here this is the opposite of a desert
guys i don't know this does not feel like the desert to me
guys i don't know this definitely does not feel like a
desert it's like here but how do i get there is it over
there the wet desert yeah guys i don't think i'm supposed to
be here maybe i'm supposed to go here What the fuck am I
supposed to go?
It's on the other side.
Did you see it?
Wait, am I supposed to be here?
Wait, Arlo?
Is that you Arlo?
What the fuck?
How did you get here?
Am I supposed to be in the wet swamps?
But it said like desert.
I can't tell anymore.
Every...
You can't tell.
But, no, it's not here.
It's past this.
It's right there.
Oh, there's trees, though.
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
Oh, God.
Where's the sun?
You need to go up.
Okay, I have to go up.
Was I going the right way earlier?
Wait, is there an up here?
Maybe there's an up here.
This is the hardest part.
I spend more time finding the goddamn colossi than at... Oh,
wait, it's up here!
Is that K?
That's, like, away.
Is that away from their destination?
I don't...
Is this it?
Is this the right colossi?
Okay.
up is down therefore wet is desert thank you for the super
chat thank you this is it i'm in a cave keep going and stay
left is this left cave maybe i think i went the right way
wait is that desert oh my god down is up me thank you for
the file i knew it i fucking knew I fucking knew it.
Down is always...
I can't believe I second-guessed myself.
I can't believe it.
Chat, I knew my gut was right.
Down is always up.
Down is...
It's never wrong!
Down is up!
Oh my god, you're a fucking genius, Doki.
You always knew which way is up.
You always knew...
You always knew which way was up, Doki.
how does she do it where is this guy oh no my son gps is not
working right now where the fuck is it yeah my son gps is
not doing so well i guess i'll go forward has to be forward
right where else could it be
How do you pass the desert?
It's a fucking desert.
Other way?
But it's a goddamn desert.
It's not this.
Oh, it...
Guys, it was this.
guys apparently it was bro what the fuck it has like duck
lips oh my god he has like those like air sacks on his chest
like frogs like multiple balls
oh no do i need the horse for this journey Arlo?
Arlo, I've always believed in you.
Arlo.
Arlo, please.
I've always believed in you, Arlo.
Sand bird.
I feel like it's a sand frog.
Because it has like those like little pouches.
It's like these like little pouches on his stomach.
What do I do?
Do I poke his belly?
Poke his balls?
Boop.
Did I hit it?
I can't tell.
Or do I actually have to steer it?
Oh god.
I hate this already.
Oh yeah, they do.
Some birds do.
Because it's like some fucking...
Like those like...
Like girlfriend dances.
Where they like puff themselves up for a female.
And stuff.
Shoot the pouch.
I shoot the pouch.
Doing finding a girlfriend.
That's fucking right.
No girlfriend for you.
Who ain't finding no girl?
Have I had anything to do with it?
No girl.
No girlfriend.
Oh my god.
I feel like you need the shot.
Jesus Christ.
No!
Yo, she got so fucked up!
That's right.
Deflate the sacks.
Doki, the veterinarian, is back.
There is a bird problem.
There you go.
You don't deserve to be in the sky.
Only one person deserves to be in the sky, and that's me.
All right, I deflated it.
No sky for you.
No girlfriend for you.
man oh I think I have to jump I have to jump on that don't I
are though please please be faster though please bro this
fucking boss fight fucking sucks okay I this is the worst
one this has to be the worst boss this 100% has to be the
worst for us because i don't know how to do this bro please
arlo please you can fucking ride faster than this arlo
please oh yeah it's not a skill issue i don't know what you
mean please please please please yes yes oh yes i did it i
did it skill issue my ass there you go It was just it's
Arlo's.
It's Arlo's fault There's no way never blame yourself when
you're gaming No, no, no, no, no, please please Here you go
Okay, now I need my sword where is the thing?
Fuck, okay There's no way he's gonna do a back look.
Oh, there it is.
It's hidden back here.
All right, it's back to my regular job of being
acupuncturist finally oh my god bro the economy was not nice
to me man i think to get so many other different jobs but
this is what i'm passionate about stabbing people's back
until they like it okay where's the other flap though oh no
look at the other flap b behind has to be on the tail right
oh god it's fine look okay we're okay i just gotta walk up
Okay, he's not gonna do the flip.
Oh, he's not, he didn't do the flip, guys.
He didn't do the flip.
That's me back here, right?
Oh, yes, I knew it.
I knew it.
Oh my God, thank God.
Where is your license?
Oh, what?
Oh, he like closed it.
Wait, do I have to deflate his sacks again?
Open up.
Oh wait, did I hit everything?
What is it?
Guys,
do you think he liked it?
Look, after every acupuncture session, he has to take a mud
bath, so, like, the mud will fill up the holes and patch it
up, you know?
So, you know how, like, I poked holes into his body, so now
he has to go take a mud bath to cleanse his skin of all the
excess toxins, and then the mud will fill up the holes,
and...
Where did he go?
And the mud will fill up his holes.
And so, like, it would, like, block out all the bacteria
outside.
Don't worry.
I'm a specialist.
Oh, my God.
He recrewed his sacks.
Bro.
How many times do I have to teach you, old man?
Can't have a girlfriend.
Okay!
Oh, am I okay?
I think I was okay.
I look dope.
Guys.
guys don't worry we're fine we're did they grow bigger it's
like a pimple you pop the pimple and it comes back bigger
the horse rotate oh my god bro you're not having a
girlfriend you can't afford a girlfriend right now you gotta
work on yourself before you can work on having a girlfriend
oh my god it's time to deflate more girlfriend for you it's
time to deflate the sacks please how am i not hitting that's
so real all right i know you need to get there closer toky
please look i'm here to give you a life lesson man look at
you where do you live in the first desert bro do you really
think this is the way to go sir you live in the goddamn
desert okay that has to be like close enough right there you
go I deflated one of the sacks all right we gotta get closer
to the other one sack number two wait oh wait sack behind me
I almost forgot this one eventually I'll hit.
I imagine.
Yeah, do it!
You don't... You miss the... You hit the shots you take
eventually.
You just gotta keep shooting.
Oh no, is he going back to take his mud bath?
No, does that mean his sacks are gonna be inflated again?
Is it filled with sand?
Oh no.
Where is he going?
No, not again.
Not again.
Guys, I don't want to do the flip again.
Wait, can I climb up from here?
Okay, don't worry.
I'm going to grab this one.
Eventually I can hit.
Arlo, please.
Arlo.
Okay.
Nice.
That must be a hit.
There we go.
We got it.
We got him, uh.
No more gold.
girlfriend.
Alright, here you go.
This is it.
I practiced this.
Right here.
Right now, Arlo.
God damn it, Arlo!
I said right here, right now!
Arlo!
Right here, right now!
Okay, this time.
Alright, where the fuck is he?
We can't do this.
Right here, right now.
It's not my fault, guys!
Arlo just doesn't take directions quite.
well yet it's like our first time arlo please don't blame
the horse blame the rider how about it's both our faults
okay how about that is that better it's both our faults okay
guys okay we both take blame it's me and arlo's fault oh god
wanna climb up climb up like this climb up yay Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, come
on, go to the other side, come on, come on, come on, yes,
okay, where is the other one, is it, like, back here, I
don't remember which one I fucking hit, there's, like, so
many things, okay, oh, it's behind, it's in the back, all
right, it is in the back, oh, there it is, there it is, here
you go, And...
Ha!
Alright, there's several more shots.
Don't worry, it's my passion!
Okay, it has to be like one more.
What the fuck?
Oh, whoa, I already finished all the...
Oh!
Please grab onto it.
I don't know which one I haven't done yet, sir!
You have so many source bots!
This would be the back, right?
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh my god, this is butt.
Oh my god, god.
Sir, you...
You need to stop by a better chair, sir.
Oh, oh my god, that scared me.
Sir, please, sir, you can't keep sitting on those cheap...
No!
Sir, I'm trying to help you.
You can't keep sitting on these cheap plastic chairs
forever.
Please, open up.
No!
Alright, guys.
Guys, I don't think he wants...
Guys, he's just taking another mud bath.
my god not a round three not a fucking round three this is
dirt bath time he's like a fucking chinchilla all right here
we go here we go here we go again you can and well sir you
have to keep you have to fucking let me massage the ass i
gotta poke the ass and let out the stress
You have to get better chairs.
You gotta stop fucking buying those cheap plastic chairs.
Those long chairs.
They're not good for your butt.
At least put a cushion on it.
One more time.
All right.
I swear to God if I have...
Sir, please.
I told you.
Now is not the right time to have a girlfriend.
Stop doing...
Nobody is watching.
No female...
No female is watching your dance right now, sir.
You gotta work on yourself first before you do all of this.
Please.
You literally live in the goddamn desert.
Look, I am a professional.
It's acupuncturist first before female.
very passionate about my job oh my god do not look at the
way i aim right now there you go there you go there you go
all right oh my god this has to be my toughest client yet
bro you're getting charged extra man i'm gonna put all those
hidden keys like a hotel
all right i'm gonna put all those hidden bees in that
fucking bill soon.
Okay, we gotta...
We gotta climb up again.
I'm toky, bro.
Look, it's not my fault.
He's a tough lion.
All right.
He's just a really tough lion right now.
Are you fucking... No, please!
God damn it.
This is the worst.
words he's gonna use young doesn't choose to live in the
desert he just can't bro the red is just insane it's like
almost like new york city oh my god please and the hardest
part is just jumping onto these things are you kidding me
oh my god What do you...
I hate this.
I hate this one.
There's gonna be so many enemies.
I'm gonna try to, like, triple the price, and then I'm gonna
add a commercial fee too.
Alright.
Come on, come on, come on.
Please, Arlo!
No!
Please!
I can't!
Why is he so fucking
up?
Oh my god!
guys guys please guys for all you bond watchers you might
have to skip five minutes into the stream
for all the bond watches just just wait like five more
minutes and then we'll get there i swear just wait five more
minutes air pouches again I have a feeling oh there's no way
there's no way oh I fucking gripped it go
we keep going we have to keep going we fucking delayed so
much that we gotta head to the ass please head to the butt
get to the butt it's the only way it's so far from the ass
oh my god it's so fucking far why are you so long okay it's
way too long man all right here you go god it's just all
body no ass please worst appointment ever don't call me back
and we will never service we will never fix your stress
again
I This is the worst one I'm gonna fucking charge so many
hidden fees Worst customer
I'm badding him.
I'm gonna take a picture and then put him on the bad list
You know, like those convenience stores where they're like
never servicing that person again.
That's him bro You're the worst client I've ever had
everybody else was so nice.
This was my passion too.
I can't believe it.
You ruined my passion.
Wes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So that was your favorite one, right?
Ban forever.
Don't call back.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ban from life.
Alright, nice.
It's so nice that they always transport me back to my home.
Look at that.
See?
They love this.
They love my work so much.
They always Please take me back home.
Is that great?
Oh my god, please tell me I don't have to drive the horse
anymore.
Please.
Please tell me that was the last time I have to drive the
horse.
Please for the love of God.
A guardian set loose.
A closed off city beyond the channel.
I don't know.
Where's that?
That's not desert.
Unless we're destruction.
Okay, it's not the desert.
That's a win in my book.
No desert.
Win.
Win time.
Yay!
No desert!
Let's go!
No more deserts!
Let's fucking go!
As long as there's no more deserts.
That's all that matters.
Senpai, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Pray to save.
Let me pray.
There we go.
Adoki, shout out from Brazil!
My belly hurts from laughing at that sassy tomato girl.
Tell me any plans on playing Splatoon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Definitely in the future.
I know there's Splatfest tomorrow because like two of my
friends they're like s plus plus plus rank like the highest
rank possible is it x rank they're like oh wait it's an x
rank right the highest rank possible and they invited me to
do some splat fest but i was like guys i haven't played
splatoon a long time so we're gonna do it off stream because
they're like hardcore splatoon players you guys might know
them uh pokey and uh gg and like you might know who the two
artists are because they're like really uh they've done like
a lot of for hollow live um i know like pokey has done like
uh like a lot of like well-known art pieces for um for uh
for hollow and demon dice if you guys know like her music
videos and stuff and uh you know pokey like the pokey pokems
yeah yeah they invited me to play some like spittoon off
stream like they were deciding with the off streamer off on
stream and uh and you know like the artwork where like it's
like the all when they debut she would draw these artworks
where it's like those like pokemon cutouts and stuff uh with
like the faces and then the little chibis in the bottom like
they're like really famous artwork in the hollow live
community and uh and also like she's done like artwork for
music video artworks for demon dice and stuff um um really
amazing artwork and like gts like it's like the xenoblade
fanatic and she's like done um She has done like a lot of
like famous like Xeno Blade artwork and stuff like fan art
and stuff as well as like drawing some some Drawing some
like Popular artwork for Halo 2 and like they invited me to
play some Splatoon Offline or offline online and I was like
you guys are too good I was like guys you guys are too good.
We play off stream and then next time we play on stream
because I rank possible in splatoon i'm like guys i know
guys we we play off stream and the next time we play on
stream together because you guys are too good
um but they're really they're amazing people they've also
like recommended me uh recommended me like some
manufacturers for merch and stuff because they're like
really well known in the artist alley scene and uh and
they're like uh they i was asking them for like
recommendations for like some manufacturers like uh plushies
and other stuff too uh because they've like made plushies in
that past with artist alley so it's great too asking them
for it's nice having like artist friends especially artist
friends that does like artist alley and stuff because uh um
yeah when you're level 99 friend invite the level three
friend yeah that's It's me!
It's me!
Because like they know all the fucking good manufacturers
instead of like the bad ones so I can ask them for
recommendations and stuff.
Um, instead of like trial and error some manufacturers.
Alright.
Anyway, sorry I can't multitask.
I'm so bad at multitasking.
Where the fuck do I go?
Poop, poop, poop, poop.
Okay, it's this way.
Alright.
this way so i couldn't have that fucking zatsu because i was
so bad at multitasking
um but yeah i've been friends with him like uh for a very
long time like when i was just a really small streamer uh
because like uh where the fuck do i go is it across the map
again it has to be it's across the map i've been friends
with him like but for a long long uh for for a while now uh
before uh before before you know started like actually
vtubing um and like i think like we met when because when we
were like art streamers when we when we did like art and
stuff and like i noticed that like uh they know uh cantonese
and stuff so i was like oh my god you know cantonese i know
cantonese and then we like bonded over that and we like
raided each other and we're like super small art streamers
And then, you know, like, we've been, we became friends
because of that.
Like, we're like, you speak the same language!
I speak the same language!
And then that's how we, like, met.
Yeah, like, when we were all, like, small art streamers and
stuff, we, like, rated each other.
I think it was, like, before, VTubers were a thing, too.
Before, like, not VTubers, before, like, like, uh, before,
like, HALOEN ever, like, debuted and stuff.
like vtbris were still like a new concept in the western
side have i been to that shrine before can't tell yes i
can't tell
oh my god i can't tell if i've been to that one oh my god we
both it's like same hat same hat
Arlo, sometimes I wish you can just jump across this cliff.
Like, can't you do a cool trick like this?
Arlo, come on, Arlo.
Why can't you do cool tricks like that?
Okay, it's this way.
It's this way.
Yay!
Alright.
Have I been to that shrine?
I must have.
That's like a shrine in the middle of fucking nowhere.
Wait, have I?
No, I haven't.
It hasn't been activated.
Oh, wait.
Wait, I haven't.
I haven't activated this fucking shrine.
It's, like, in the middle of nowhere.
Alex, thank you for the farm.
Get the ships.
Thank you.
And say bye.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Okay, she rolled her eyes.
No, absolutely.
This is, like, the closest.
Everyone always makes fun of me because I can't roll my
eyes.
I don't get it.
Fuck it.
I'm so glad.
I can't.
Oh, there you go.
is a little pipa that's like the closest i can to like
rolling my nose is that look i'm trying my best here like
what the fuck all right where the fuck did he go but this is
a little oh there he is okay let me grab my bow gamer still
alive so there you are not alive anymore okay this is like i
i want to test my theory out about like if we can do an
infinite food glitch with salamanders it's like okay like
i'm just saying if they can like you know it's like you can
eat worms and stuff right like it's like what was it you
know that like children's book about eating worms god what
was it they always make you read that fucking book that old
book about
uh what is the cod what is that cod that worm how to eat
fried worms yes yes it's just like that i'm just saying we
can fix like it might not be like if we can we can like put
like um because we can have technically we can have infinite
food food glitch with worms if you think about it and like
it's all about how you how you season the worms you know
Okay, it's this way.
I'm going to do the jump.
Goodbye, Arlo.
Wee!
There's no way I die.
See, I'm fine.
I have so many... I eat so much fruit that I'm fine.
All right, at...
Speed ride.
I'm just saying...
Okay, well, no, you just raised the children off of a
worm-only diet.
So they never know what actually tastes good.
Like...
It's just all about, like, the same thing.
seasoning if you have put it good enough seasoning it'll
eventually taste good and then all you have to do is just
like it's so fucked up it's still food the child has no
concept of what what is good food like you raise him like a
bird you mean it's still food i don't that's so cruel
divide.
Okay, look.
Salamander tails and worms.
Is that better?
They're a healthy diet.
That's enough meat, right?
I read thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's enough meat, right?
Where the fuck is...
Where do I go?
No, that's not it.
I'm sad.
Most normal dirty tangent.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is not it just I'm just trying to figure out how to
like do the infinite food glitch Are you not curious out of
science?
For science you're not care about science tific reasoning
Why don't we just farm real animals because you can't do an
if because when you farm real animal okay Are you trying to
say worms are not real worms deserve like rights to
like okay the thing about farming real animals is that you
have to where the fuck do i get across the thing about
farming real animals is that eventually like it takes too
long to farm them that's the whole issue real animals just
take too long to farm but like but like if you like cut a
worm and like or like you know grab a salamander's tail they
eventually regrow it in like multiple times so like all i'm
saying is like starfish we can eat starfish too because they
can regrow their limbs think about it we just eat the
animals that can regrow themselves
guys think about it and then we don't have to worry about
like we don't have to build more farms to like we don't have
guys think about we don't have to build more farms to like
uh to fix like the like you know we don't have to demolish
more forest forest and like to build more farms to build
more like uh okay so what about the vegans and the
vegetarians well
what about i guess we'll grow fruit i don't know i'm
thinking about like the meat lover problems right now.
We'll tackle vegans and vegetarians another time.
This is about like, we'll tackle, we're tackling problems
one at a time, guys.
There's too many problems in the world.
Okay.
That's what grass, that's why we're talking about the
stomach scenario.
Okay, where do I go?
Do I go straight?
Is there, is, am I going the right way?
Am I going the right way?
Is it up?
It has to be up, right?
I feel like I'm not going the right way.
Wait.
Is this the right way?
Up, I believe.
I don't know.
I don't even know, guys.
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
To the left?
Have I been here?
Yeah, I have.
Is it the left side?
this floor I need to figure out where to go it's like here I
guess like this way it's close to the which fish I've like
fucking killed so many like aquatic creatures this is this
way am I going the right way guys I can't tell it has to be
the right way eight hours later This has to be the right
way, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I'm so smart.
I think I'm right.
All right.
I think I saw world hunger.
Guys, I think I saw world hunger.
If people aren't like pussies about eating worms and
salamanders, we'll be fine.
Like, eat worms or 600k Scoville chicken with no milk.
the 600k Scoville chicken um because that shit is like not
that spicy to me
all i'm saying is that people are cowards people are fucking
cowards there's just not it's who cares about what a food
tastes like it's all about getting your proteins right as
long as we get our proteins in we're fine why is why do you
care about what a food tastes like but toky why don't you
try it out then lead by example look okay I can't like lead
by example if no one else wants to like lead with me okay
this is a group effort I can't do this on my own guys I
can't do this on my own it's all about working together you
Look, we're here to work together.
It's not a race here.
It's about teamwork.
It's our ideas.
We cook this idea together.
It's not your idea.
It's our ideas together.
Because we're a team, dragons.
You and I were a team.
What happened to being a team?
guys we came up with this idea together you do not want to
solve world hunger that's fucked up chat
ah yes dokey manipulation that's so healthy
manipulation and gaslighting that's that's so healthy i've
did it
all right here you
this is it where is he where the fuck is the guy
where is he
where do i go where the fuck is the colossi oh it's here
there's like a little hole here Down the hole we go.
A red flower.
What the fuck am I going to do with a red flower?
Where is this guy, anyway?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god, he's like a guard dog.
I've killed his brother.
I mean, I've...
I gave his brother a belly rub.
Hello.
Who do I do?
Is he going to, like, knock me over again?
What the fuck do I do?
I do sir sir what is your problem what problems do you have
sir oh my god you can jump what do I do what time hello I'm
right here sir what the fuck do I do he has your heart I
find No, I don't know what to do Oh, no No, what the fuck do
I do?
What the fuck?
Oh, wait, I'm okay Wait, that didn't hurt Wait, I'm okay Oh,
please, okay, never mind that hurt That hurt Alright guys, I
fouled up Please get up, it's just a little concussion Get
up, oh, he didn't see me Oh, thank god, okay Hardcore this
oh do i climb this and then i jump over there i think so
right where let's put our climb thank god okay parkour
parkour okay it's parkour time watch this one foot okay and
then climb up now what do i do i'm king of the world
i heard a reboot in king of the hill we're gonna do?
I have the hard ground now.
What the fuck are you gonna do about it, huh?
That's fucking right.
Nothing, because I'm taller than you.
If you're taller, you're smarter.
Hello?
What are you doing?
What can I do up here?
I thought I fell.
I shot the ass.
Wee!
Wait, I actually made it.
Where's the other Oh my god, did you guys see that?
I actually made the jump.
The cutscene jump.
What the fuck?
Gaming!
That's when you know I'm a gamer.
Get yourself.
Look at yourself a dokey that can fucking do the cutscene
jump.
Did you see it?
Circle emoji.
Do I have to do another?
jump here later you have to do a cutscene jump all right
come on come on do it again now i'm a now i'm now i'm
professional parkour artist i have many jobs i'm shooting
the butt again that's right are you gonna do about it huh
that's right come on charge me again oh shit oh shit with me
god i actually thought i was gonna miss all right here we go
again come on do it again it'll be so funny
come on that'd be so funny i'm so cool
guys guys i don't think it i don't think he thought it was
funny guys because i don't think he thought it was funny
guys i don't know why but i think he i don't think he
thought it was funny all right last minute save i told you
i'm a professional parkour artist all right here you go
all right another one all right another one where do i jump
from here like there i guess there right there's no more
areas to jump to oh again again again come on bro what are
you so fucking pussy your
wife left you okay
nice and then we jump from here we up we go up we go come on
sir we need to do again we gotta fix your concussion too we
all know to fix your concussion just gotta keep it's like
amnesia you know you hit your head You remember everything
when you get concussion just guys don't follow medical.
I'm not a doctor I might be like licensed in many things but
doctor isn't it Just so you know Just so you guys know We
might have a lot of licenses in multiple things But anyway
as I was saying We're gonna fix your concussion sir This is
like non-licensed medical advice But like you know I think
if opinion.
You know how those Twitter accounts were like, these are all
just my opinion.
I'm not associated with any company or like my... This is
only my opinion, but like, I think if you like hit your head
again, we can un-concuss your concussion.
All right, this way.
I have to go this way, right?
I don't know where do we go.
My opinion is a magic word.
I fucking know God I'm literally doing it right now God
where else am I oh it's this way okay God I'm literally
doing the thing God what the fuck am I I barely see it okay
here you go up we go up we go where do I jump after this
like here
Where do I jump?
God is backseating me.
God is like, where do I go?
Okay.
In my opinion, sir, if you keep hitting yourself against the
wall, we'll fix the head concussion.
But this is just my opinion.
You know, if I was wrong, it was you're the one that
followed the opinion instead of getting actual visual
message.
medical advice.
That's your fault.
Okay, watch where the tower falls.
Okay.
Come on, knock it down.
Okay, this way?
Where is that man falling?
Where am I?
Oh.
Ow.
Get up, please.
Get up.
Where did that come from?
Here?
I go up.
I must go up, right?
Oh shit!
Thank you for the taxi ride, I guess.
Sir, please.
Give me a sec.
Up I go.
I'm gonna go from here then.
Like here?
Where else would I go?
Here?
Just down here?
Come on.
Right here.
is the flower like my yellow spray is that supposed to
represent the yellow spray oh it is
oh my god the red flower is the new yellow paint i brought
down the roof
oh my god finally Finally, but also where am I?
How do I jump on his back, though?
No, I'm gonna do something.
I see it, I see it, do you see it?
Circle emoji, did you see that?
Whoa!
There we go.
All right, it's time to fucking fix your back, sir.
Just like how I fix your wife's back, who's totally still
alive.
It's almost the same.
Yes, she left you.
She's not dead or anything.
She definitely just left you Okay, oh nice that nice that
nice not nice right now Oh fuck.
Okay, bro, bro calm the fuck down Your wife like oh my what?
I'm up here now.
Okay
Don't worry.
I can make this jump right?
Yes nice Oh, thank God.
Thank fucking God.
Okay, now I can poke.
Now I can, like, fix his back.
There you go.
Let that juice out.
There.
The wife loves it when I did this, too.
You're totally alive.
Very much alive wife.
Look, it's not my fault she left you.
All right, with, like, no letter or anything, too.
That's so fucking weird.
That's so weird, man, that she, like, left you with no
letter or anything.
She just disappeared.
Like, where else would she go?
And then you could never find out And she never called back
or anything She even like left all her belongings to her at
the house It's like she never cared Alright Not even like
Gave you like any messages Not even with a text or anything
You're very much a live wife Oh my god please Let me fix
your back I'm getting sad Why?
She's alive!
She's very much alive.
She's just left with, like, no other messages or anything.
Like, all her belongings were still in the house, too.
It's so fucking weird.
But, like, there's no foul play.
She needs to ram into something.
Please, ram into something right now.
So I need you to ram into something.
Okay, fuck this.
There you go.
Little by little.
I will force myself to punch you're back for health reasons.
It's so healthy.
Take your
hands.
Okay, nice.
He just stuck there.
Did I glitch?
Did I glitch him?
Like, why is he not moving?
He's, like, not moving.
moving at all.
Combo time!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna combo this person.
It's like when I put him in the corner in a fighting game.
I think I fucked him.
There you go.
Pro gamer.
He's taking the treatment so well.
Oh my god he's so relaxed that he just lied to me.
backing us back he fell asleep never punished let's go
that's how you do it infinite we're doing it we're scheming
so hard is that my girlfriend my very much alive girlfriend
not like the guy's very much alive wife
oh my god so many happy customers guys i think i'm doing it
look at all these happy customers right there
there's actually a spot on most if not all colossa that you
can grab and will never be shaken from speedrunner tech
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you it's gay i
appreciate it
there's two more
that next foe is that has fallen into the valley
clock thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i sit
there and shake my head 48 times a row too if you told me my
wife was gone thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you yes you're very much a live wife who left like no no
other evidence that she left you other so crazy that she
even left all her belongings and her cash too.
And like, even the car.
But like, she's very much alive.
There you are.
The very alive wife.
Let's see.
Where do we go?
Oh yeah, we got safe to pray.
Pray to save.
Is this NTR murdered?
You'll never know.
That's a good question.
Final next time on the next episode of dokeybird all right
we gotta save the prey very of course it's not murder she's
very much alive
this way all right this is like literally this entire like
the let's play through has been 80 trying to figure out
where the i am
I swear we spend less time Other than that fucking Terrible
bird client Other than that client The air sack client All
the fucking colossi murder Like sorry colossi patient
Colossi clients Have been pretty easy to deal with Like my
job has been pretty easy What was that now?
Patience Patience clients My very much alive clients okay
this way i'll go this way no no no you guys must have like
had us all you guys must have had like a small stroke right
there what murder i would never
go arlo go go arlo go
i meant like a murder of crows a group of crows you know
yeah yeah yeah you know murder as in like a group you know
like you know when they say a group of crows and i say a
murder of crows it's like on the other side how do i get
there what do i get there oh god how do i where the fuck is
that area have i been to that shrine no i haven't oh wait
that's i've been to this shrine
all right let's grab this shrine first save the prey whoo
there you go yay we did it okay where the fuck is the
salamander this might be our last salamander oh there he is
god he's all the way up there again god damn it get down
from here you're not a fucking bird oh wait nope
Nice.
Oh, shit.
He's, like, all the way up here.
No!
Don't know how to climb up there!
No.
No, you're not gonna have that privilege.
Where did he go?
God damn it.
That's right.
A fucking vibration.
No.
No!
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he fucking walk to?
I hear him.
Where is he?
He's on the ground?
They can do that?
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right, Linda.
No.
There you go.
I got it.
I'm going to double kill you.
Nice.
All right.
We did it.
Yeah, they walk on the ground now?
I was like, What the fuck?
He can be on the ground?
Alright.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
Oh my gosh.
It was so difficult.
Where is this last one?
It's like right here.
Do we go across this bridge?
Right?
I can't tell.
Guys, do we go across this bridge, chat?
Is it this bridge?
Okay.
I just want to be sure.
yep no okay where the fuck said that west okay two people
said no more said yes west i'm gonna remember your name if
this if you were wrong do it you won't oh this is the forest
wait this is the forest i don't think we go here wait i
don't think this is it yeah this is not the bridge we got
okay west might have been right everybody else was wrong oh
we do not okay okay i remember like the other area led us to
nowhere it's not this bridge oh my god in the end west was
right i can't believe it i can't believe west was right all
along he's lying
don't listen to him he's lie okay this way all right here we
go this has to be the right way yeah has to be here where
else can it be he's lying i definitely have the guide open
okay all right into the desert we go it's like somewhere to
our right follow the sand okay follow the sand who the fuck
said yes before too i didn't even remember that guy's name
instead god damn it i remember the wrong person's name i
always need to remember the people that run so i can float
behind the castle there's a castle i wonder if i can go
right from here has to be right where else would it be
there like a passage here Oh, there it is.
Is that a castle?
Oh, my God, that's a castle.
There is a castle.
I'm not the only person here.
They have... A human has to make that castle.
Oh, my God.
There's a shrine here, too.
I get to eat another salamander.
Alright.
Pray to save.
Where the fuck is the little bitch?
Oh, there he is.
okay the vibration is gonna knock him off god damn it
arlo all right there you go nice
yummy all right he gets to live for my infinite food glitch
you can't save all of them arlo i'll eventually eat all the
salamanders all right here this way To the castle we go!
He gets to live.
That salamander needs to thank Arlo for saving him.
I was just about to eat him too.
This was like this way, right?
That way to go in?
This way?
What a way to get in, is there?
Just like this way?
Where is the castle door opening?
Oh, here.
Found it.
I found it
Wee Okay, there's a hole right here That means the hole is
the goal Okay, how the fuck How?
Oh, the wrong entrance There's another entrance There's a
slope here there's a front entrance wait what you mean
there's more than one hole well guess we're gonna find out
wrong hole apparently oh my god there is what the fuck guys
did you guys know god gave us more than one hole All right,
here we go.
I found it.
I love the songs they make.
You and I.
And your friend Steve.
We did- Out their hole!
What the fuck?
Oh, it's this way.
Guys, why the fuck are they random holes?
It's baiting me so hard.
Oh, you don't know that song?
And my friend Steve.
Steve.
Wait.
Okay, this is actually one of my favorite songs.
It's so funny.
and his friend Steve can't believe it me you and Steve it's
Garfunkel and Oats one they also have like a lot of other
really good videos a lot of other really good songs too here
it's 15 years ago holy fuck bro it was a good song
all right no I'm not listening to this song on my stream I
have enough fucking copyright strikes guys music people have
taken enough of my money all right up we go can you not run
up seas mr.
protagonist bro what the fuck is he he's a giant right Then
where is he being a giant at?
Where is he?
Hello?
Giant?
Sir?
Steve.
Hey.
Where is he?
Giant, sir.
Where are you?
If you're such a giant, why can't I see you?
Oh, there, I see you now.
Whoa, hey, you know what, they were right about you.
You were pretty big.
King Khan.
Bro, I didn't mean it when I said I couldn't find you and
that you might be sure.
It was just a hee-hee-funny joke.
Fuck you out of time.
God, what do I do?
God.
Help me.
Oh, shit.
I don't think he liked it.
I don't think he liked that.
God, what do I do, God?
Oh my God.
Can I climb anything?
Can I climb anything around here?
God, please.
God, God, it's time.
Goal.
Survive.
Oh no.
King Kong's gonna fucking grab me, man.
Okay, I'm running.
I'm running.
There has to be a thing to clap.
This has to be climbable.
Nope.
Okay.
This has to... Nope.
Yes.
There has to be something out there that's climbable.
Climb him.
Where?
Oh god.
This is climbable.
This has to be climbable.
Please, where are the climbing parts?
I used to be able to climb everything!
Oh, no.
Panels.
God, please, I'm struggling again!
God, show me the way.
Okay, his head is his heart.
Okay.
Oh, my God, there's panels?
Oh!
Is this a panel?
Are these panels?
There's so many squares around.
There's so many squares.
Fana, please.
I'm trying.
I can't climb.
Oh, my God.
This is climbable.
Guys, I'm figuring out the climb.
And then I jump here.
and then all right and then what do I do and then okay no no
okay all right I'm gonna make you stop here this is
apparently this is apparently a panda I think yeah I don't
know about this one either wait he's walking a ramp right
away am I not like guys I'm important sir sir sir i'm
important too sir you're like please sir oh my god i did one
damage guys i did it guys i think it was happening okay guys
don't just get like that like a little mosquito okay is he
gonna stomp on this stop stop stop stop stop one damage
let's fucking go What are you looking at?
What's he gonna do?
Hello?
What is he gonna do?
Nothing!
He's stuck!
Look at him!
Look at that little coward!
He's fucking stuck like a baby!
Come on, do something!
Do anything!
whoa oh my god i did it oh my god i'm so fucking smart i
fucking did it he stepped on the panel i've always known
okay now i'm up here now i'm up here what do i do now is he
gonna is he gonna duck down he made me a little ladder maybe
he's a good guy after all Do you see that?
Do you see that on his arm?
It's like a little pimple that I'm gonna poke.
That I'm missing every shot.
Bro, it's your weak spot.
Okay.
No, don't leave me!
I'm a threat!
Sir!
Okay.
Come on!
I'm mean.
I'm a scary, mean person!
Come on!
You need to turn around.
Ignore me!
Bro, give me your arm!
Your underarm!
Broar!
Look at me!
I'm threatening!
Look at my hand!
Look at my bow!
Come on, turn around!
Turn around!
Stop moving.
Oh, bro, he's ghosting me.
It's as if I'm not scary enough for him.
That's fucked up.
I built up a clientele that deserves to be noticed, sir.
Now turn around.
Is he gonna do a growl at me?
What's he doing?
Is he trying to have a conversation with me?
oh shit okay oh my god he's having a tamper tantrum right
now bro how the fuck is this knocking me around okay bro
said you ain't it bro i'm trying to help i'm gonna shoot you
in the ass if you don't let me help you oh he's like
ignoring me bro am i not important guys guys Am I...
Am I not important?
No way.
No, there's no way I'm relevant, right?
There's no way.
I have to be relevant, right?
No, not that way!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
You were turning around!
Go up higher?
I can climb up higher?
Wait.
I can?
Where?
Oh my god.
Guys.
No?
Look.
Ow.
What the fuck do I get higher?
This?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
That's an accident!
No!
That's an accident, please!
No, but steady.
That's an accident!
Turn your fucking head!
Please, for the love of God, just let me shoot you in the
arm.
Let me shoot you on the fucking...
Please.
Bro, please.
For the love of God.
Just turn around.
I need your other arm.
Your other arm has the weak point.
There's no weak point here.
There's literally no weak point.
Stop moving.
Okay.
I'm trying.
So hard.
I swear.
Come on.
Hey, that's right.
That's me.
Now give me your arm.
Give me your arm.
Give me a little poke.
Yes.
I moved that.
Yep.
I moved that arm.
Come on.
You know you want to.
Look, I did damage.
Ow.
Look at the damage I did so.
Look at that damage I did.
Please, just show me your other...
Oh my god.
Show me your other arm!
That's all I want!
Bro, I fucking swear.
Hey, I fucking swear.
Just try and hit something.
thing
oh my god finally oh i'm okay i'm okay but he finally did it
holy shit are you fucking kidding me oh now you okay now you
fucking okay we did it guys it took him 20 years but we
fucking did it i don't know why it took him that long this
had to be the longest strike of my life i watched him dance
longer than this like
i spent more of the time watching him dance where does he
strike here we should make him strike here no no no no no no
no no no here okay maybe here oh i got this
What did I do, dummy?
What did I do?
I hit it.
What now?
Okay, now he just has his arm.
What if I just do it again?
Oh, okay, never mind.
What now?
Is he gonna pick it back up?
Nice, I fixed his arm.
I gave him a shot.
Shot, shot, shot, shot, shot.
can he is he gonna slam this go to that bridge oh there's a
bridge there's stairs guys there's fucking stairs oh my god
there's stairs guys i did it i found the stairs i can't
believe we wouldn't slam down for so long wait maybe that's
i'll need the sword here
me.
Fight me right here.
Now I'm taller than you and that means I'm more important.
That's fucking right.
Get a little closer.
Come on.
Hey look, try to jump on him.
Is he gonna do slap?
He's gonna slam.
He's gonna slam it.
He actually is gonna slam it.
Guys, it was did the thing holy fuck damn oh my god he
actually slammed it who would i thought this
is crazy man he actually did it all right i need him to stop
in here who's taller now guys i need him to stop on this
guys on me on me right here that's me A teaser, yes, it's
me.
Please, I want to be tall just like you when I blow up.
Please.
Stomp on this.
Woo!
Ow.
That's all right.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you for the little booster seat.
And then I'm up.
I'm up.
Yes.
Oh, fuck.
How did I miss?
It was like only one way to jump and I still miss.
Oh my god, this is so hard to see.
angle all right where is it here oh there it is there's the
stairs stare time stare time yeah
don't worry we got this all right i am here ready for our
appointment for real this time he was a little feisty but we
did it we convinced him i guess i just jumped on him from
here that's right get over here we're not behind schedule
because you wouldn't fucking swing the other side why the
other side i can make it from here watch
okay i actually did not think it would work but
I could punch your tie.
Let's let him go.
Who's the other side?
This is that Doki way.
Never doubted.
Where are my believers?
Where are my believers in chat?
That's lucky right, it was for you guys.
Nice bead, right?
other side i don't need other sides i just need one side all
according to plan oh wait it's gone now oh wait what the
fuck wait what wait excuse me what is it excuse me what do
you mean it's gone whoa shit excuse me oh where is your
where are your other spot
There's other spots?
There's other spots that give me help on?
Oh, I see it!
It's right there!
Right?
Is it right over there?
Oh, no.
I'm gonna recharge real fast.
I'm gonna stay up here and recharge.
We'll be fine.
He's just being a little feisty right now.
Wait, no, that's a spot to drop the sword.
Did you see it?
Guys, what the fuck?
He had other spots?
No, I know what I'm doing.
I'm a professional.
I get paid for this.
I don't totally know where it is.
No, no.
fuck it i mean i know where it is guys i definitely know oh
it's his head what the fuck can i like climb and hold my
head up get over here
where where how the fuck do i just have the head is that
shooting what if i just keep shooting the man okay maybe
it's here okay maybe he like goes up here and then i just
like just hold his hand come on right here step on this step
on it oh my god there you go watch this okay no not yet not
yet not yet don't watch it don't watch it okay am i okay i'm
okay watch this guys i'm gonna hold watch this he's gonna
get close to me and then i'm gonna hold the hand oh my god
it's right in the hand how the are there is there fur on the
hand i can't tell i can't tell if the hand has fur that i
can like grip on come on slam it oh my god come on please
this is for your own medical concern right here all right is
he gonna slam are you gonna slam now i'm just gonna move
what are you doing what the are you doing just slam what are
you doing are you dancing here it's your slam it's gonna do
it come on come on swing your hand oh it's flexing why are
you shy bro just move
What are you doing, bro?
Oh my god, I'm going to fucking shoot you.
Just slam!
Don't be a little bitch!
Are you...
We're just standing there menacingly.
He's just wiggling.
There's nothing I can do.
He's just...
What do you think?
What fucking...
There you go.
I'm gonna shoot you in the hand if you don't get over here
right now.
Oh my god, why the fuck did I like make him lose his axe?
Oh my god, if I didn't make him lose his axe, this would
have been so easy.
I just had to shoot his arm.
I just had to do that.
Come on.
Do it.
Swing this.
You know you want to.
This is me.
Right here.
Come on.
I'm like so out in the open.
So defenseless.
Just do something.
Anything.
Oh my god.
You're pissing me off.
I'm gonna give you hidden fees as well.
You're gonna have hidden fees as well, man.
Okay, I'm gonna, like, go up the level on this side, then.
Come on, at least stand on this panel!
This hidden feast hat.
Come on, stand on it.
Nice.
Wait, wrong panel.
I can work with that, actually.
Yeah, I can work with it.
All right, this way.
All right, up another floor.
can't see what's going on on my camera but i think i'm okay
okay all right here we go now it's time it's time for to do
this again don't worry we don't need the other side yeah i
can't but thank you for this yeah thank you thank you he has
performance anxiety here we go again get
all right This is it.
Right here we go.
I knew it always works.
I knew it.
I think it's this side, right?
Which arm is it?
Guys, give me a sec.
I need to remember which arm.
Guys, is it the left arm or the right arm?
Chat.
Wait, can I actually grab the arm?
Is it the right?
It's the right arm, yeah?
The sword arm.
No!
Let's go!
Oh, shit.
Here we go again.
Oh, bait a hand swing.
Oh, is that it?
I go in the middle and then I bait.
Okay, here we go.
I got this.
Swing that arm.
Swing it.
No, no, no, not the feet!
Swing that arm.
Come on.
Do it.
Swing that fucking arm.
Swing it.
Please just keep swinging.
You know you want to.
Oh my god, he's swinging the arm.
Oh my god, he's doing it!
No!
That's okay, I figured it out.
Okay.
Hold the arm!
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Please, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Don't get closer.
I just need you to swing that arm.
Jesus Christ.
That window is like...
The window to like...
Oh my god.
Knock a leg again.
No, don't get closer.
Please, with the love of God.
But what if I hold this?
No.
No!
please this is a medical emergency what if you have cancer
on the hand let me see not medical profession but
professional but right now just just in case not medical
professional but like i'm just trying to like help please
please your hand glowing is not a good sense No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no
Please!
It's just one stab!
Oh my god!
It's literally one stab!
Okay.
He's baiting me.
He's fucking baiting me.
Bro!
You fucked!
He is actually baiting me so hard right now He's trolling me
He's trolling me right now He actually is Give me your arm
Give me your fucking arm Wait You can walk past that You can
walk past that Oh my god
He walked over it I can't believe it I'm so sad I've been
stuck in this room.
I could never get him to let me check his hand He won't let
me check his hand.
I don't understand I'm so sad
Please I all I asked just let me Let me grab the hand Please
It'll be so fast.
It's just a little bomb not the feet Not the feet I meant
the hand get that shit away from me get away be gone
Oh my god, not the other foot not the other foot I didn't
mean give me the other one
Sir, please.
Am I far enough?
I should be far.
Oh, my God.
Sir, I told you, get that shit away.
It's not the feet.
It's the hand.
Alright, this time.
This is the longest fight we've ever had, just because he
wouldn't give me the hand.
I swear to God.
Peace, peace, peace, peace, peace.
Ah!
Yes!
Oh, he actually held it there!
Oh my god, I've held it ahead!
Don't worry, it's just a benign pimple!
Don't worry!
It's just benign!
I'll pop it really quick with my sharp sword!
I'm burning so there's no bacteria on the sword!
Oh, thank god.
Bro, this was the worst customer I've ever had.
I cured him.
Done.
Oh, my god.
I'm blacklisting this customer.
Holy shit.
Good job holding his hand.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This was worse.
This was worse than the bird who was trying to find the
girlfriend.
We literally needed to just hold his hand.
And this fucker was too shy.
He was too scared.
Another happy customer.
Never return.
I'm closing my doors for this customer.
Yay!
Two people in the black.
I guess I was like, this is one of the easiest ones.
And I swear to fucking God.
I swear
my god was bugged out or some shit there's no fucking way he
had to be bugged out because it took me so long
Oh it's nearly over I'm about to complete the ritual to have
my girlfriend back guys guys I'm gonna make it
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
Alright, time to pray.
Oh, Harlow.
Oh my god, Harlow.
That guy fucking sucked.
I hope he never called us back and asked me to fix his
problems again.
Bro.
This guy is forever banned from ever.
I'm gonna fucking block his number He's never I don't care
how much he pays man.
That guy fucking sucked
That guy fucking was terrible man.
He wouldn't fucking he kept giving me his feet.
I was like bro I was like sir sir.
I'm not a feet doctor sir Sir I need the hand not the feet
It was terrible.
He wouldn't fucking stop Even if he paid a billion Let's see
that right there's like Messages that like people who do
like only fans and then like they get like they like post
like the types of tweets and DM To a type of DMs they get in
private messages.
They'll be like I'll give you like I'll give you one million
dollars if you can give me a
Excusive picture of me I've seen like Twitter message like
Twitter post Back then of like Girls like girl like they
don't even do any Like those like OnlyFan stuff they just
like They just post on like Twitter like Pictures of
themselves and they will get like Private DMs and stuff and
being like Ma'am I know like you don't offer any of these
But like what if like I give you like A hundred thousand
dollars just one Pictures ma'am just one I'm like, what the
fuck?
And I was like, holy shit.
And they're just like, guys, you know, a million's a
million.
Like, to the left, not here.
Like, just regular, regular, like, not just women, but,
like, regular guys who are just, like, regular, like, women
and men who are just, like, good-looking.
They get, like, random DMs and stuff about that.
And I'm like, whoa.
Whoa!
Yeah, Saudi Prince.
True.
Yeah, that's real Euler.
Alright, wrong, wrong entrance.
Where do I go?
There's nowhere here.
Do I go to the right?
I mean, for a million.
Do I go to the right or the left?
Where is I want a hundred K?
is it right side check mask which way self self is down self
is down okay self is this way okay all right oh you mean
like is it that one to the right is it this one
is it that entrance over there to the far right Wait, how do
I zoom in?
Is it like here?
Wait, uh, like over here.
You see where I'm... Okay, you guys might not know where I'm
looking at, but...
That little hole.
Right there.
That little hole over there.
Right here.
Like, right here.
I don't know if you guys can see it.
hole.
This has to be the hole, right?
I'm gonna look at the right one.
Alright, right here.
Alright.
Hello, where the fuck are you going?
Okay, just follow this.
Don't worry.
I have autopilot on for Arlo.
Thank God for autopilot, Arlo.
All the way down.
So, like, all the way down there, at the very edge of the
map...
Uh...
I guess I'll go this way.
Actually...
Does it matter which way I go?
I'll go this way, actually.
Yeah.
Okay.
All the way down, Arlo.
This is gonna be a long ride.
We're at the finish line, Arlo.
You know, I can't wait after finish this game to play Hello
Kitty Adventure.
one of the best games ever made i never played it before but
i i i expected to be one of the best all right let me just
go straight down yeah hell yeah bring on hello kitty hello
kitty the critically acclaimed sequel sequel of what like
there's a there's a first what but i've never heard of it
okay it has to be the cloud all the way down here use the
sword i mean i don't need to know use the sword if i know
it's like down there's no way go back up go back
can you figure out how to get down okay give me a sec any
holy thank god
That was a little risky.
Guys, that was just...
Just a little risky.
Just a little bit.
Whoa, I stopped myself before anybody got hurt.
Whoa.
That was...
That was a little wild of me to do.
Just a little wild.
Ooh.
Go...
Oh, now you jump off cliffs.
Okay.
It's like this way.
It has to be like in between those two cliffs, right?
It has to be.
Here we go.
Where else could it be?
Come on, Arlo.
You can do it.
Come on.
Arlo, come on.
Don't be a little pussy.
All right, eventually Arlo will drop down with me, right?
Arlo.
Come on.
Hello, come on.
You're going to teleport right behind me.
Anytime now.
Anytime.
Hello, are you teleporting?
Hello?
Hello, you're going to teleport, right?
Oh, he's going the long way.
Oh my god, he's smart.
He actually went the long way.
No, he doesn't quit.
Look, see?
Look at him.
What a good horse.
Oh my god!
I made it.
I hit the jump.
I'm a professional horse driver.
Alright.
This way.
Here I go.
Yay!
It has to be this.
Okay, and then I raise my sword.
And then I hit it.
Yeah!
I did it.
Yippee.
Okay, where?
Arlo, get over here.
I need to keep my five stars, Arlo.
Okay.
Okay, no, no, no.
I'm right here, Arlo.
No, no, no.
Right here.
What the fuck?
Is it...
Do I go up here?
Wait.
Where do I go?
What the fuck is the...
Here?
Arlo?
Right here?
Oh!
Sorry.
Yeah.
Use Arlo?
I don't need a use Arlo.
Is it here?
Oh no, where's the sun?
Where did the sun go?
wait i do need arlo arlo apparently i need you wait is that
shrine oh shit okay guys give me a second i need to go to
the shrine guys i need to go to the shrine
arlo can jump across he can there's no way there's no
fucking way we need to pray first give me a sec pray pray
pray oh my god now you don't believe in god anymore pray
okay this is it okay we need to find the lizard i hear him
but like where is oh there he is it's like hiding up here
i got the tail did you just see that i specifically hit the
tail need to figure out how to climb this.
Oh my god.
There we go.
I don't like how there's no sun.
It doesn't make me fuck.
Okay.
I don't like that.
No, are you fucking kidding me?
Alright, jump.
Jump.
Alright.
Here we go.
Yay!
Alright.
Alright, though, please.
Apparently I need you.
Apparently they said I need you.
Oh, God.
No.
I'm going to drive this horse.
Please.
Hello, please.
There you go.
Nice.
Okay, and then...
Up we go.
Oh.
Here we go.
And then...
This is where we do it.
Make the jump, Arlo.
I believe...
It's time.
Can we make this jump?
We need 10!
No!
It's okay.
Guys, Arlo can swim, right guys?
Guys, guys, Arlo can...
So quick, I'm sorry, let me look at my screen.
No, Arlo!
Guys, I have empathy.
I swear to God.
We all know horses can swim.
They're fine.
They can swim.
We all know they can swim, guys.
Horses can swim.
If I can swim, so can Arlo.
Oh, why?
guys if i can swim so can arlo guys we all know this we all
know this guys like we all know this am i going the right
way i can never tell i assume it's this way
i assume i'm not gonna sugarcoat it though he don't what do
you mean i didn't want to bring arlo i wasn't gonna bring
him along you guys me I was gonna protect Arlo I wanted to
protect him D dragon it was a D dragon thank you the super
chat thank you thank you guys that's fucked up guys you guys
did that I was gonna bring him a lot I wasn't gonna bring
him a lot no you killed Arlo not me it's okay horses don't
take fall yeah horses don't take fall damage right frozen
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you guys fall
damage guys that's what minecraft taught me wait actually no
wait horses can die from fall damage guys this isn't like
this is like arlo minecraft guys it's okay he had water no
he thought they don't take fall damage if there's water they
don't take like they don't take fall damage if there's water
chat wait i wasn't supposed to this is just an easter I
guess I'll grab the Easter egg Since I'm here I guess I'll
just grab this You gotta recharge Where do I go then?
Huh?
I wasn't even supposed to be here
No, no I'm okay I ate so much fruit I'm gonna see to the
right Guys, do you guys know if you hold it You jump further
away I wonder how long have people been yelling at me to
hold my ex Guys, you guys, I just found out guys Guys, oh my
god I just found out that if you If you hold down, you can
jump further.
Holy shit.
Makes me wonder how long people...
How long people have yelled at me.
Really?
What makes you wonder?
Where do I go, though?
Was it not this way?
Oh, wait.
i don't know which way to go i assume like maybe like this
way
i'll go this way i have no idea where to go i'm a little
lost oh shit did i go the wrong way was it this way this
entire time guys i think i went the wrong way oh my god i
guess there was a possibility I went the wrong way this
entire time.
Wee!
Oh, this way.
This way.
Wee!
Wait, we lost our guide.
I don't know what to do now.
We lost our horse guide.
What do I do when we don't have a guide?
Is this a colossi?
Am I climbing a colossi right now?
There's no way, right?
No, I don't think so.
This can't be, right?
I don't know, it looks fucking weird.
I feel like I'm climbing a colossi.
Like, why are there grasses growing around?
It feels like...
This feels like a colossi.
Because it's built so weird, too.
Alright.
Inside I go.
Inside up I go.
Up.
Up up.
Alright.
Whoa!
How do I go from here?
What?
Okay.
Jump up?
Oh, I do.
Oh my god, guys.
I feel like, um, if...
Oh my god!
Yeah, I was not climbing.
What the fuck?
He's like, Samurai Jack.
Yeah, I was not climbing.
I was not climbing because I was not climbing.
I was not climbing.
Bro, how do you have screens on when...
When it's raining?
Yeah.
more like samurai jacked
wait he's like pointing at me me oh he was not pointing at
me
guys he was not I'm okay
guys he was after me what the fuck guys I need to figure out
how to get there Oh my god Because he was absolutely What
the fuck you How how?
I'm gonna heal up.
I'm gonna heal up guys.
I'm not okay.
I'm not okay Oh my god, how do I get closer?
How the fuck do I get closer?
I'm healing so slow too.
Okay.
Let's go down.
What?!
That's bullshit!
I...
He hit me in the air!
Holy shit!
That guy fucking hit me in the air!
That's so fucked up.
Not the heal.
the hell he actually hit me in the air all right guys a
little super chat reading time because um um i need to regen
my hp apparently thunder insanity is doing the same thing
over and over again expecting different results thank you
for this super chat thank you we're gonna have to sit down
and do some super chat readings because uh he fucked me up
real good you guys hero thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you where is arlo when i need him cucumber thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you where is he
where's arlo arlo where are you i didn't think of the super
chat thank you thank you arlo would have been able to outrun
this man he would have I've been able to outrun his fire
blast.
Okay.
Where do I go from here?
Oh, shit!
This is like bullshit.
Why does he do like 200,000 damage?
Oh my god.
How does he do so much damage now?
What?
Where do I go?
what i'm trying i'm trying to find cover bro okay guys back
to back to super chat reading uh say thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you thank you uh frozen thank you super
chat thank you thank you just saying island web dodge those
blasts thank you for the super chat thank you guys guys it's
back to back to the being a floor fast.
Okay, here we go.
There's no way he gets me down here.
There's no way.
There we go.
We have cover.
Where do we go from here?
Maybe right here.
Okay, and then run!
Now where do I go?
Run!
There we go.
We made it.
Oh my god, we made it to the other hole.
We did it.
right up we go i'm learning i'm learning the rolls they've
taught me to roll
we go where do we go from here to not climb no i have to go
this way okay i thought i could barely see where i'm at okay
there's no way he could see me i'm camouflaged the power of
dodging This is my dark souls up there, man.
Okay, I was gonna...
I was gonna say it.
There's no fucking way I'm gonna die today.
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm in the hole.
I'm in the hole with a goal in mind.
I'll not go.
Here I will.
I go up.
Here I go.
And then climb.
And then we're...
I'm getting closer, guys.
Look.
I can see his skirt from up here.
Oh my god, please.
Please!
Why can't you get up?
You...
Okay.
Go right, I think.
It must be right where else would I have to go.
Run!
Guys.
Okay.
Run!
bro oh nice all right nice we did it i was so confused
because i saw i saw stairs i was like do i do i do something
that like i was taught to do against i was like here's
stairs oh shit i'm looking up
guys i think i might get arrested guys
Oh god.
Where do we climb?
Here?
Oh here.
Okay, we got it.
We got it.
Nice.
I think it's just parkour.
This is all parkour?
Past.
Where and what's going on?
This is the wind working against me?
That's a thing.
I grab onto this shoot in air
you're gonna do heal he's so funny okay I'm climb up here am
I going up I can't tell
get a nigga jump jump from here oh my god this is gonna take
Fucking forever.
Bro, he's so fucking tall.
This man is so tall.
It's gonna take fucking forever to jump up.
What do I do from here?
Is that thing gonna get closer?
There's no way I'm gonna hit that jump.
So it has to be that over here, right?
No, there's no way.
It's not gonna move closer.
Let's not go this way.
I don't think that's gonna move any closer to me.
Okay.
Okay, where's his heart?
Oh yeah, it's like way up.
Oh my god, I can get closer.
Okay.
I'm getting so close.
Here we go.
Arm time.
Only up.
Oh god.
Oh,
there's a spot!
Oh, there's a spot!
He's right here!
That's right!
Is that it?
Did I do it?
Did I fix his back?
I fixed it!
Wait, do I grab the hand?
Oh my god, it's like fast track.
It's like fucking fast track right here.
Sorry, that was the most primal scream I've had in a while.
flash before me I swear I thought I had to do this all over
again what a save oh my god I had the most primal stream oh
my god that scared the shit out of me I actually scared the
shit out of me holy fuck okay we're not doing that again am
I bro I
All right.
Swing.
Here we go.
That's the jump.
Okay, we do it again.
We do it again.
Holy fuck.
That was so scary.
That was so primal.
You guys have no idea how fucking scary that was for me.
Throw him back.
God
Bro, I fucking hate this so much Not again Oh, yeah Not
again Why is it so difficult?
He's joking.
It's so hard to grab the harp Oh my god, that's just sad
It's just look, it's the gorilla all over again It's the
It's the gorilla all over again, chat It's the fucking
gorilla Curse I blame the gorilla curse, guys It's the curse
of the Gorilla
The curse of the gorilla
Oh my god, what the fuck, what can I Look at this.
Okay, here we go.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Hold on to his...
Oh, wait.
Do you mean he lifts his hand to his face?
Guys, I didn't know that.
I thought I had the climb of the arm.
Like the other...
Like the bird guy.
Okay.
We're going here again.
Here, third time is the try.
This time I got it.
Okay, I just have to climb.
I just got hold on.
I knew
it.
No.
Just climb.
Please.
Just fucking climb.
Just climb.
No.
No, don't let go.
Don't let go, Jack.
Don't.
We gotta poke you again.
So I can have a better pull down for this.
No, no, I...
No!
Please.
Just jump.
Oh, I
got...
Nice.
Not nice.
Oh, oh!
Not nice, guys.
Not nice, not nice, not nice.
Not nice.
Please tell me there's something to grab on here!
Oh, thank God!
Oh, thank God, oh, thank God, thank God.
I think I fucked it up, though.
Unless...
No!
This is right up from the...
Alright, here we go again.
All of them are getting blacklisted.
Fuck all of these guys.
Alright.
Do I jump?
Do I get down?
Please get on top of the pump!
Stab the head!
I did it!
Stab
the backwards!
Guys, I think I went backwards again.
Guys, I went backwards.
I...
But there's fire!
There's fire though!
I'm scared!
Let
me recharge a little, we gotta recharge a little.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa,
whoa, whoa!
Okay.
Oh no, please, I'm so scared.
Just chill, just chill, just chill.
Oh, I see it, I see it, I see it!
Did you see it?
I'm scared, I got scared, I thought I fucked it up!
I said I fucked it up!
Oh my god, I thought I fucked it up!
We're okay.
Guys.
I'm so scared.
Oh no.
Oh god.
I'm so scared.
Guys, I'm so scared.
The other shoulder?
Oh, it's right here.
It's right here.
Oh my god, we've made it.
No!
Oh, shoot me!
We fucked!
Chili's such a cool- That was so close.
That was so close.
Oh my god, that was...
Not quite, I fucked it all up, guys.
Okay.
We made it.
We made it!
Oh!
We gotta get closer.
One last acupuncture!
Oh god.
Sir!
You need this.
It's for you!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Stop!
Just let me do my job!
Okay.
Jesus Christ, why is it safe to still lie?
Mine like not at the head?
I can't tell because I'm swinging so much!
Okay, here we go.
I couldn't tell if I'm poking it correctly.
Zing!
That sounds like me.
Not gonna lie.
That sounds just like me.
look he keeps swinging his head of course I was gonna miss
eventually oh my god I'm getting a little scared now I feel
like I'm gonna fall now not gonna lie charge it just a
little bit nice okay oh thank god okay I didn't miss this
time sorry I might have actually hit your brain but don't
worry don't worry um here is a coupon um for one free head
massage uh Don't worry, sir.
Don't worry.
They weren't the important parts in your brain, guys.
It wasn't like the important parts in the brain.
So do not worry.
Do not worry, sir.
You'll be fine.
Okay.
I'll do a full charge of five.
I have no time.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I have one more stab.
One more stab.
Come on, sir.
Sir, it's okay.
Oh god.
I saw myself stumble.
It would be a doki moment if I fell right now.
It will truly be the most doki moment.
No!
You fucking kidding me?
That is what it should be.
I mean, like, one more stress point.
Boom.
We did it.
The Doki Bird acupuncture experience
Oh my god, all that stress toxin coming out right now Where
am I?
Don't have me.
Oh shit Nightmare slain I did it I'm a hero Oh my god,
they're coming to my turn turf.
Get out!
This is my clientele!
What does he have, a white horse?
How does he get to be so special?
What is he doing on my turf?
Here, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The rival acupuncture.
What are you doing?
Bro, he has a mask, too.
That's when you know he's, like, a fucking professional.
Did you remember to pay your protection fee?
I am the protection!
What do you mean?
This is my turf!
Oh my god, is she better now?
Is she healed?
Lord Imon?
He gets to be a Lord?
Oh, that's when I killed the last Colossus.
Yay!
it's so roomy now there's like look at all the space
i get the taxi back to home
is she better now
i did it i healed my girlfriend now it's toky turns for
being stabbed noisy thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you what do you mean i'm the good guy right that looks
like a good guy right there is he doing yamcha pose
Oh my
god, I can fly now.
That's the Peter pose.
Oh yeah, you're right.
That's more like the Peter pose.
The family guy pose.
What are they doing to my girlfriend?
What are you doing?
Hands off.
That's right.
Or I'll get very angry.
oh my friends are here oh my clients my five-star review bro
i look so okay
what have i done i got my girlfriend back
Look, if it was forbidden, you should have made a sign.
Of course now.
I'm like a horned angel, right?
Angels have horns, right?
Oh!
My knee!
Bro, what?
Skyrim hasn't come out yet.
Oh my god, this was...
The last...
The last colossus walked so Skyrim can run.
Acupuncture, no!
Not the...
No way!
I mean, it's like hair salon, people.
Wait, am I gonna die?
oh my god my stress juice i was so fucking stressed the last
acupuncture it's just acupuncture
whoa hey sir i think you missed bro you know what i was
pretty stressed out i was definitely pretty stressed out
yo I finally got my own obsession at
least talk to my boyfriend she looks live she has blood in
her face now
look all the stress is coming out
I was so fucking stressed man
another happy client
what the fuck each
colossus was a piece of god that's still the good guy
You can't beat a bad guy.
He's got...
Wait, am I gonna kill him?
Oh my god, I'm the good guy!
Let's go!
Whoa!
I'm good!
What the fuck do I do?
fucking right i'm the good guy dokey smash i can't see
anything where am i getting hit by where are the people at
you're so tiny oh my god where are they oh here you are
there i see you i got you in the corner
That's fucking right.
Doki Smash.
For justice.
Damn!
How do I keep missing?
Can you guys, like, walk a little further up so I can, like,
actually hit you guys?
Okay, I'm trying to, like, figure out the perspective.
Okay.
Guys, I realized, like, guys, I realized.
that like being colossus is like really difficult
no they're getting away god how are you so slow
more you no wonder they were so stressed out
No, I know how they feel.
What's he gonna do?
Where am I?
Just throws the sword?
What?
Oh,
his mask, it's handmade!
Oh, and it's still there.
That's good.
No!
I have so far, girlfriend!
It's like, I can't believe the good guy's losing.
I couldn't even...
Y'all grab onto it!
Go!
Can you grab the wall?
If I learn everything, I just need to grab.
Oh, fuck it, let's go.
Hold on to something.
I've accepted it.
I accepted it.
Just grab something.
My license for your books.
I can't believe it!
How did they know this wasn't a real license?
How did they know?
How did...
I can't believe the inspector came!
I did my job perfectly!
I watched the YouTube guys!
I can't believe it.
The inspector came.
Who called on me?
Who, like, ratted me out to the inspectors?
To the acupuncture inspectors.
They just left her?
all that?
I guess because they thought she was dead.
She's alive!
Look at her.
Now she's less dead looking.
I'm gonna be like, how the fuck did I get here?
She's like, what the fuck?
Where am I?
The power of acupuncture.
It works.
Even my license wasn't real.
My skills were.
She doesn't even know where the fuck to go?
Oh my god, I can control the camera.
Arlo!
I knew it!
Minecraft was right!
I knew horses can swim!
I fucking knew it!
Arlo!
Are you limping?
Oh no!
Oh Starlo stealing your girl broken bod.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I fucking knew what minecraft was right We did it
Saved I knew I was the good guy all along Oh my god We
fucking oh these are all the dead that colossi have killed
Oh, they like become one with the nature Afterwards We did
it chat Oh my god We fucking did it We beat the game Another
game completed We did it Thank you for coming to that
journey I'm shadow class Classes Wait is there an after
credit Alright let me turn down the sound a little bit
there's an after credit okay all right nice all right we'll
wait until the after credit then oh my god good job i did it
thank you i won poor jester thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you oh my god what a journey what a journey
opening up my massage parlor being the very best and still
having my license taken from me can't believe it i was It's
like those like honorary degrees.
I should have gotten honorary license for all the all the
colossus I've saved.
The fucking stress I helped get rid of.
Someone had to call the inspector.
No fun.
And our Arlo and girl get to eat grassworms and lizard tails
in this peaceful land.
They give us a super chat.
Cass, thank you.
Thank you.
a job too i got like five star yelp reviews and everything i
don't understand i don't i don't understand how did how did
this happen
oh that was really fun i don't know what series to do next
week though i'm trying to think of like what my new series
should be There's so many games I want to play.
So I don't know which one to start first.
I might do...
I don't know, actually.
I don't know which game to do next.
Because there's, like, so many I want to play.
There's so many games I've always wanted to play.
So it's always hard to figure out the next series.
But I have, like, a backlog of...
I wrote down a backlog of games that I wanted...
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, it's still going?
Oh, my God.
They're breaking the bridges.
on top of that bridge?
Uncle Mako never.
What the fuck?
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can't have your license taken away if you never had one
to be gone.
Oh, true.
True.
I have an honorary license.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
You could be on top of that this whole time.
I've always been under there.
I saved my girlfriend.
What do you mean?
I mean this whole game was about climbing Just climb Was
that it?
Was that the after credit?
Bro, are those fucking limping?
What the fuck do I do?
Like What do I do?
Like we don't have a horse doctor here I don't even know
what the fuck My girlfriend can do He's just being dramatic
the fact that he like swam all the way back back here wait
am i alive i'm a baby
bro still oh my god bro what my girlfriend's gonna be my mom
now
Oh wait, is this didn't mean oh, that's like eco She's like
he's like the spiritual success like the prequel to equal
eco because he has horns too Bro my girlfriend's my mom I
knew guys I fucking knew grabbing anything was worth this
I fucking knew it You guys are like dokey why didn't you
grab anything I fucking knew there was There's no point.
I saved up some time.
I saw my chat.
They were like, wow, this entire game was grabbing and she
doesn't even grab at the end.
Because I knew it was useless.
There was no fucking point.
But what about the drama?
I should have been like, Wee!
Jumped into the pool.
Wait, but the bridge is gone.
How the fuck is she gonna get home?
This is so sad.
Like, seeing Arlo limping.
Oh my god.
Bro, how the fuck do we fix his leg?
This is home now.
Yeah, I'm like, how is she gonna... The bridge is gone.
Where are we gonna get diapers.
Kill it.
The deer.
Why is this no white shit?
She's so close.
Kill it for food.
Oh my god, this is great.
Because like the the herbivores have never seen an actual
carnivore before.
So it's like the dodo bird.
It's like a dodo bird where like dodo birds never
encountered any like actual um actual like uh threat so like
it was so easy to kill all the dodo birds because uh the
dodo birds just didn't know what is considered a carnivore
and what is considered like a predator so so the dears they
don't know they don't know so we'll just wait for it to walk
up to us and then like snap its neck and then that's food
because it's never seen the predator before eagles don't eat
deers okay maybe like baby deers I've seen an eagle pick up
a fucking baby deer before like not in real life but a
YouTube video not root it's not ruining them what moment it
was a fucking deer you never seen a video of like a fucking
eagle pick I think it was like an eagle picking up a fucking
baby deer it's just like because like there's there's like a
thing so a lot of parents are like super paranoid because
like there's been cases where like eagles will try to pick
up children like we'll try to abduct kids because it sees it
as like a fucking baby animal yay
yeah eagles can pick up goats now there's a fear in there
yeah we did it now you have an additional fear if you become
future parents and then like now you're like what if an
eagle picks up my child my child will never go outside
anymore new fear
yay we fucking did it guys oh my god we fucking did it we
beat shadow colossus press x real fast Enter your attack
mode Press in front of the cross A statue What the fuck Did
I just beat the game?
Oh new game plus a mirror world What the fuck is mirror
world?
Anyway, I beat the game!
We did it!
Another game completed!
I'm gonna turn off the game I'm gonna turn off my
PlayStation real quick I'm gonna turn it off Oh my god Oh
yeah, as promised As promised I was gonna show you guys the
new sub badges let me uh i need to grab the uh uh let me
grab like the files real quick oh my god i need to find it
again did i put as oh oh he's so bad just okay here here
here i'll show you guys it's so cute oh my god i even have
they gave uh my friend even gave me like alternatives like
alternatives Sub badges.
There we go.
Let me show you guys.
It's so cute.
Oh, it's so fucking cute.
Woo.
Okay.
Downloads.
I put it in my downloads again.
All right.
Sub badge material, guys.
Look at this.
Look at this, guys.
Look.
It's so tiny.
It's so cute.
Look at the little.
Look.
They gave me alternatives with, like, the little
handkerchief or, like, the non-handkerchief.
I went with the non-handkerchief because, like, I felt like,
you know, I wasn't allowed to look dissimilar.
But, oh, my God.
And then there's me.
There's me over here.
I sort of, like, baited my friend because, like, even
though, like, I commissioned them to draw me, we're going to
get a new skin suit.
gonna change in the future like we're not even gonna hit
that subbatch it's just there for decoration i just wanted
to fill it all the slots up but like we're never even gonna
get this subbatch like the last one
yeah the last subbatch is gonna change and i was just like
this is just fuck it i just wanted it just wanted it's just
a placeholder yeah it's gonna it's a placeholder so the new
would be different from this.
JP, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki from four years in the future.
Hell yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tatsuya, thank you for the super chat.
Can I ask for a birthday greeting to Scarlet Ghost?
She's a huge fan from you, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Of course.
Happy birthday, Scarlet.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Scarlet.
see you yeah my birthday um also another update if you guys
don't follow me on twitter uh so you know how like uh gamer
subs and i are hosting a art contest um gamer subs got back
to me and they are sponsoring funding the whole 8 000 for
the prize pool so like originally it was 7k but then we
decided to add i wanted to add an extra 1k and choose like
10 more winners because there's been we've recently like i
checked we've had 120 entries so far after one week and
there's still like three four what three to four more weeks
left of the three to four more weeks left of the of the
contest so i was like oh i wanted like i was like oh my god
and there's so many there's so many they're all like really
amazing they're all like so pretty and everything so that's
why like i asked if i could add one more one k more to the
prize pool so i can like pay more artists for amazing
entries because it's going to be so hard to choose Matt it's
gonna be so hard to choose and then gamer subs after they're
like yeah they're like you know what Doki we're gonna
sponsor all the entire prize pool like all eight thousand
dollars of it because at first it was they sponsored 5k I
sponsored 2k to the 3k and then later on today they told me
that they are gonna sponsor like full fund the entire 8000
so huge shout out to gamer subs for um for the for the big
support there for willing to like sponsor eight thousand
dollars for artists it's actually crazy so crazy um but yes
uh thank you all for joining i'm gonna fucking peace out now
i'm super tired i'm very tired now we stream for four plus
hours so i'm gonna peace out now guys oh yes had a great
time watching as always everybody stay hydrated posture
check get up and move around for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys
bye